I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello.0. Hello. Hi.
我是詹娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极办公室爱好者的播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量的VFF故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是Office Ladies 6.0。你好。0. 你好。嗨。
Today it is all about Angela Martin, and it is also Angela Kinsey's birthday celebration. It is, it is. You guys, I walked into, I mean, just such a beautiful arrangement on the table. You guys clearly know me. There were roses, a cake, a little bottle of rose. Yes.
今天是关于安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）的，同时也是安吉拉·金西的生日庆典。没错，确实是。各位，我一走进来，我的意思是，桌上的花艺布置太美了。你们显然很了解我。有玫瑰、一个蛋糕，还有一小瓶桃红葡萄酒。对。
A little sloth for my tea. Yes, you put like loose tea leaves inside the sloth and then he hangs on the side of your cup. He's so cute. I can't wait. And then maybe my favorite, it looks like a pad of butter. Yeah. It looks just like a pad of butter, but it's notepad.
一个用来泡茶的小树懒。对，你把散装茶叶放进树懒里面，然后它就挂在你的杯子边缘。它太可爱了。我等不及了。然后也许是我最喜欢的，它看起来像一小块黄油。对。它看起来就像一小块黄油，但它是个记事本。
It's like sticky notes. Lady, I've had that butter pad of paper for so long and I've been saving it to give to you. I'm so delighted. The day has come. I'm so tickled by it. And then there's some bags, but I'll wait and open them later?
就像便签纸一样。女士，我拥有那个黄油形状的纸垫好久了，我一直舍不得送给你。我太高兴了。这一天终于来了。我被它逗得乐不可支。然后还有几个袋子，但我晚点再打开它们？
I think you should open them now. Oh, OK. I'm so excited open them now. Oh, OK. I'm so excited to give you these gifts, Angela. I think maybe they're the greatest presents I've ever given a person for any occasion ever. Wow. I'm so excited. And I had help.
我觉得你应该现在打开它们。哦，好的。我好兴奋现在就打开它们。哦，好的。我好兴奋能把这些礼物送给你，安吉拉。我觉得这可能是我有生以来在任何场合送给某人的最好的礼物。哇。我太兴奋了。而且我得到了帮助。
I'll explain. OK. I want you to start by opening the small bag. OK. I love it. You have to read the bottom. It's a hummingbird mug. There's hummingbirds love it. You have to read the bottom. It's a hummingbird mug. There's hummingbirds on it. It's clearly handmade.
我会解释的。好的。我希望你先打开小袋子。好的。我太喜欢了。你得读一下底部。这是一个蜂鸟马克杯。有蜂鸟，太可爱了。你得读一下底部。这是一个蜂鸟马克杯。上面有蜂鸟。这显然是手工制作的。
And they're surrounded by flowers. To Angela, Jenna is sorry. Because about a month ago, I broke your hummingbird mug that we got from Katie Bowler. I know. By accident. You were doing the dishes and it just slipped off the rack. broke your hummingbird mug that we got from Katie Bowler. I know, by accident. You were doing the dishes and it just slipped off the rack. And lady, I contacted Katie and I asked her
而且它们被鲜花环绕。致安吉拉，詹娜感到抱歉。因为大约一个月前，我打破了我们从凯蒂·鲍勒那买的你的蜂鸟马克杯。我知道。是不小心。你在洗碗，它就从架子上滑落了。打破了我们从凯蒂·鲍勒那买的你的蜂鸟马克杯。我知道，是不小心。你在洗碗，它就从架子上滑落了。而且女士，我联系了凯蒂，我问她
if she would make you another one and she did. It is so beautiful, Katie. I love it, Jenna, thank you. I didn't want to make you feel bad, but I was really sad. I knew you were really sad because you were going out of your way to not make me feel bad, which was a major tell that you were so bummed. And you know, during season nine of The Office,
她是否愿意再为你做一个，她真的做了。它太美了，凯蒂。我太喜欢了，詹娜，谢谢你。我本不想让你觉得糟糕，但我真的很伤心。我知道你真的很伤心，因为你一直在极力不让我感到难过，这是一个你极其沮丧的明显信号。而且你知道，在《办公室》第九季期间，
my beloved Pam mug fell on the ground and broke. I remember. I know what it's like to lose a precious mug. A favorite mug. Yes. This is so beautiful. Thank you both so much. Well, I asked Katie to make you something else.
我心爱的帕姆马克杯掉到地上摔碎了。我记得。我知道失去一个珍贵马克杯是什么感觉。一个最喜欢的马克杯。是的。这个太美了。非常感谢你们俩。嗯，我请凯蒂为你做点别的东西。
Oh my goodness. And that's in the big bag. Okay. You guys, oh, this is so beautiful. It is this beautiful pitcher that you would like put water in or iced tea, and it's got these beautiful plants etched on it. She's such a great artist. And it says, for the plants.
哦，天哪。那在那个大袋子里。好的。各位，哦，这个太美了。这是一个非常漂亮的壶，你可以用来装水或冰茶，上面还刻着这些美丽的植物。她真是一位出色的艺术家。上面写着：“为了植物”。
Lady, that's because the pitcher you have in your kitchen Great artist. And it says, for the plants. Lady, that's because the picture you have in your kitchen where you put all your leftover water, we were saying someone came to your house and they accidentally drank water out of it thinking it was for people. And I said, you need a picture that says for the plants. I do.
女士，那是因为你在厨房里的那个壶，是一位出色的艺术家。上面写着：“为了植物”。女士，那是因为你在厨房里用来存放所有剩余水的那个壶，我们当时说有人去你家，不小心从里面喝了水，以为那是给人类准备的。然后我说，你需要一个写着“为了植物”的壶。我确实需要。
Now you have one. Oh, this is so beautiful. Thank you all so much. Thank you, Jenna. Thank you have one. Oh, this is so beautiful. Thank you all so much. Thank you, Jenna. Thank you, Katie. And thank you, Cassie, for the flowers. Of course. Happy birthday.
现在你有一个了。哦，这个太美了。非常感谢大家。谢谢你，詹娜。谢谢你。现在你有一个了。哦，这个太美了。非常感谢大家。谢谢你，詹娜。谢谢你，凯蒂。还要谢谢凯西送的花。不客气。生日快乐。
Thank you. What a wonderful way to start the day. Well, Katie said she had never made anything like the for the plants picture before. I think it's such a good idea. I said, I'm worried people might want them. And she said, OK, well, you just tell everybody that I was so delighted to make these items for Angela, but I'm actually on pause right now with my ceramics store.
谢谢。这是开始一整天多么美妙的方式啊。嗯，凯蒂说她以前从未做过像“为了植物”壶这样的东西。我觉得这是一个好主意。我说，我担心人们会想要它们。她说，好吧，你只要告诉大家，我非常高兴为安吉拉制作这些物品，但我目前的陶瓷店实际上处于暂停营业状态。
She is getting married this summer. Her daughter's graduating from high school, but she said in the fall, she's hoping to restock. And you can follow her on Instagram at Katie's underscore sketchbook. She said, quote, if I get my act together, that's where I'll keep everyone up to date. Well, Katie, when you're ready to open your store back up,
她今年夏天要结婚了。她的女儿要从高中毕业，但她说在秋天，她希望重新进货。你可以在Instagram上关注她，账号是Katie's下划线sketchbook。她说，“如果我把事情都安排好，我就会在那里让每个人了解最新动态。”嗯，凯蒂，当你准备好重新开店时，
you just tell us and we'll share about it in our Insta stories. Aw, this was so fun. Katie and I have been spending the last month going back and forth for these gifts. I just love it. I love it so much. All right, lady, before we pivot
你只需告诉我们，我们就会在我们的Instagram快拍中分享它。天哪，这太有趣了。凯蒂和我过去一个月来一直在为这些礼物来回沟通。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。好了，女士，在我们切入
into all about Angela Martin, you know, when we did our episode all about Pam Beasley, you wore a special shirt for me to celebrate Pam Beasley. I did. You wore a Pam sass. Yes. Well, I wanted to wear a special shirt today. Wait, is this why you haven't been able
关于安吉拉·马丁的一切之前，你知道的，当我们做关于帕姆·比斯利的单集时，你为了庆祝帕姆·比斯利穿了一件特别的衬衫。我穿了。你穿了一件帕姆风情的T恤。是的。嗯，我今天想穿一件特别的衬衫。等等，这就是为什么你一直无法
to take your hoodie off? Jenna has been having a hot flash. Yes. And I said wanted to wear a special shirt today. Wait, is this why you haven't been able to take your hoodie off? Jenna has been having a hot flash. Yes. And I said off the mic, I said, take your hoodie off and you wouldn't. I said, I will eventually. Yes. So this shirt is really more in honor of Angela Kinsey.
脱下连帽衫的原因吗？詹娜一直在经历潮热。是的。我说，我今天想穿一件特别的衬衫。等等，这就是为什么你一直无法脱下连帽衫的原因吗？詹娜一直在经历潮热。是的。我在麦克风外说，我说，把你的连帽衫脱了吧，而你却不肯。我说，我待会儿会脱的。是的。所以这件衬衫其实更多是为了向安吉拉·金西致敬。
Okay. But here it is. Lady, look at you in Star Wars merch. Star Wars merch, just for you, lady. Wait, I have to take a picture of you. Did you buy this shirt special? I bought it at Disneyland. That's hilarious.
好吧。但它在这里。女士，看看你穿着《星球大战》的周边商品。《星球大战》周边商品，专门为你准备的，女士。等等，我得给你拍张照。你这件衬衫是专门买的吗？我是在迪士尼乐园买的。这太搞笑了。
Well, thank you. Yes. Angela Kinsey is delighted. I went to Disneyland with my family recently, and we went to Star Wars land. And you know, now I've seen the first three movies. Yeah. And I was just so tickled.
嗯，谢谢。是的，安吉拉·金西很高兴。我最近和家人去了迪士尼乐园，我们去了星战园区。而且你知道的，现在我已经看了前三部电影。对。我当时真是高兴极了。
I became, I couldn't help myself. I bought a shirt. Well, now you knew what different things meant. I did. I was like, look, it's the Millennium Falcon. And I know what that is. Not only am I so tickled that you're wearing that, but I know you have a whole day after this, so you'll be wearing that everywhere you go today.
我变得，我情不自禁。我买了一件衬衫。好吧，现在你知道不同的东西是什么意思了。我知道。我说，看，那是千年隼号。我知道那是什么。不仅我为你穿着它而感到高兴，而且我知道你在这之后还有整整一天，所以你今天无论走到哪里都会穿着它。
I will. All right, now it is officially time to pivot into all about Angela Martin, and I thought that we could kick things off with this haiku. A haiku? Yes, written by Kat M. in North Carolina. Here is the Angela Martin haiku? Yes, written by Kat M. in North Carolina.
我会的。好了，现在正式是时候切入关于安吉拉·马丁的一切了，我想我们可以用这首俳句来拉开序幕。一首俳句？是的，由北卡罗来纳州的卡特·M（Kat M.）撰写。这里是安吉拉·马丁的俳句？是的，由北卡罗来纳州的卡特·M撰写。
Here is the Angela Martin haiku. Little Kat Lady always seemed to be angry, just needed some love. Kat, that completely sums her up. It really does. It's a well-written haiku. And then, of course, as you know, we always like to visit the show Bible for our all about characters. Mm-hmm.
这里是安吉拉·马丁的俳句。小卡特女士似乎总是很生气，其实只是需要一些爱。卡特，这完全总结了她。确实如此。这是一首写得很好的俳句。然后，当然，正如你所知，我们总是喜欢查阅我们的剧集圣经来了解我们的角色。嗯-hmm。
And yours did not disappoint, Angela. First of all, it lists your full name, Angela Noel Martin, and it lists your job as head accountant. Thank you for noting that I am the head accountant. And then per the art department, this is a note in the show Bible, it says per art department, this is a note in the show Bible, it says, per art department, you have an address.
而你的也没有让人失望，安吉拉。首先，它列出了你的全名，安吉拉·诺埃尔·马丁（Angela Noel Martin），并将你的工作列为首席会计。谢谢你指出我是首席会计。然后根据艺术部门的说法，这是剧集圣经中的一条笔记，根据艺术部门的说法，这是剧集圣经中的一条笔记，根据艺术部门的说法，你有一个地址。
Oh. You live at 948 Bednar Street in Scranton, Pennsylvania. I never knew that. So I realized that the art department would always assign us addresses. And then I had one on my fakey driver's license for Pam. Oh. And you probably had it on anything that they made for you that was personal, but I don't think it ever appeared
哦。你住在宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿市贝德纳街948号。我从不知道这一点。所以我意识到艺术部门总是会给我们分配地址。然后我在帕姆的假驾照上有一个。哦。而且你可能在你所有的个人物品上都有它，但我不认为它曾经因为任何原因
in the show for any reason. So that's why it said per art department. Hmm. Although you also lived in Ohio at one point, season five, episode 15, that little nugget is revealed, Angela's backstory. Also, you have additional jobs. In addition to being head accountant,
出现在节目中。这就是为什么上面写着“根据艺术部门”。嗯，虽然你在第五季第15集也曾在俄亥俄州住过一段时间，那个小细节被揭示了，也就是安吉拉的背景故事。此外，你还有其他工作。除了担任首席会计，
Angela Martin was also head of the PPC and safety officer along with Dwight. Yes. I made a list of Angela Martin's dislikes and likes. OK. Here are Angela Martin's dislikes. Thinks green is whorish. Also thinks orange is whore-ish.
安吉拉·马丁还与德怀特一起担任派对策划委员会（PPC）负责人和安全官。是的。我列出了一份安吉拉·马丁不喜欢和喜欢的事物清单。好的。以下是安吉拉·马丁不喜欢的事物。认为绿色很婊气。也认为橙色很婊气。
Doesn't like to gamble. Nope. And then I thought, considering that she has filed a complaint against everyone in the office, she probably dislikes everyone in some way. Someone... Everyone has bumped her at some point. Yes. Angela Martin does not like germs. She is constantly sterilizing her hands and she wears a mask to work.
不喜欢赌博。不。然后我想，考虑到她对办公室里的每个人都提出过投诉，她可能在某种程度上不喜欢所有人。某人……每个人都在某些时候得罪过她。是的。安吉拉·马丁不喜欢细菌。她经常对手部进行消毒，并且上班时戴着口罩。
She does not like Movie Monday. She is offended by the Kama Sutra. She thinks malls are awful and humiliating. She does not like making people laugh and she does not like murder mystery games. But she has a number of likes. Okay, let's hear them. She's a very balanced person.
她不喜欢周一电影日。她对《爱经》感到被冒犯。她认为商场糟糕透顶且充满羞辱感。她不喜欢逗笑别人，也不喜欢谋杀之谜游戏。但她有很多喜好的事物。好的，让我们听听。她是一个非常平衡的人。
There is a yin to her yang. She likes the colors gray, dark gray, and charcoal. She likes performance reviews as she enjoys being judged. She likes babies dressed as adults. She thinks it's okay to drink. She has sleep apnea and likes to read before bed, but she hates mysteries because she hates being titillated. So I get a little bit of a like dislike there. She is a history buff and she enjoys Ben Franklin's lecture.
她的阴对应着她的阳。她喜欢灰色、深灰色和木炭色。她喜欢绩效评估，因为她享受被评判的乐趣。她喜欢打扮成成年人的婴儿。她认为喝酒是可以的。她有睡眠呼吸暂停症，喜欢在睡前读书，但她讨厌悬疑小说，因为她讨厌被撩拨。所以我从那里得到了一点喜欢和讨厌的平衡。她是一个历史迷，她喜欢本·富兰克林的演讲。
And of course she loves her cats and dressing her cats in outfits and she also licks them and she sleeps with them in bed. and she's dressing her cats in outfits and she also licks them and she sleeps with them in bed. So Angela's cats are a very famous part of her personality. Oh yeah. Her identity. And when we had our interview with Billie Eilish,
当然，她爱她的猫，给猫穿上各种衣服，她还会舔它们，并且和它们同床共寝。而且她给猫穿上衣服，她还会舔它们，并且和它们同床共寝。所以安吉拉的猫是她个性中非常著名的一部分。哦，是的。她的身份。当我们的采访对象是比利·艾利什时，
you guys did a cat naming contest. But do you know how many cats Angela has? How many cats? She might have more. So maybe I should say, how many cats does she mention in this series? Oh my goodness. Is it around 13?
你们进行了一场猫咪起名比赛。但是你知道安吉拉有多少只猫吗？有多少只？她可能还有更多。所以也许我应该说，她在剧中一共提到了多少只猫？哦，天哪。是13只左右吗？
It's more. How many? 18. 18. I was gonna guess 13 or 17 and I went lower. And I have all their names. Oh, great. Here they are. For the record.
更多。多少？18只。我本想猜13只或17只，结果我猜得更少。而且我拥有它们所有的名字。哦，太棒了。它们在这里。为了记录。
Yes. All 18 cat names. Sprinkles. Yeah. Garbage. Bandit. Although, and I'll get to this later, there's a big fan theory going around
是的。全部18只猫的名字。小饼干（Sprinkles）。是的。垃圾（Garbage）。邦迪（Bandit）。虽然，我稍后会讲到这一点，但有一个广泛流传的粉丝理论
that garbage and bandit are the same cat. So 18 names, maybe 17 cats. Princess Lady, Mr. Ash, Petals, Comstock, Ember, Milky Way, Diane, Lumpy, Philip, Tinky, Crinkle Puss, Bandit Two, Pollock Baggins, and Lady Aragon. That's all of them. I mean, I just love, love, love that she has a cat named Diane.
认为垃圾和邦迪是同一只猫。所以18个名字，也许是17只猫。莉莉公主（Princess Lady）、小灰先生（Mr. Ash）、花瓣（Petals）、康斯托克（Comstock）、安伯（Ember）、银河（Milky Way）、黛安（Diane）、兰比（Lumpy）、菲利普（Philip）、丁基（Tinky）、克林克尔·普斯（Crinkle Puss）、邦迪二世（Bandit Two）、波洛克·巴金斯（Pollock Baggins）和阿拉贡夫人（Lady Aragon）。这就是全部了。我的意思是，我就是喜欢、喜欢、喜欢她有一只叫黛安的猫。
I know, of all these names. That is my absolute favorite. But I would say almost as famous as Angela is for her cats, she might also be famous for her lovers. She has a few. While she has called Pam the office mattress and was disgusted seeing Michael and Donna making out, Angela Martin has had sex with Dwight in his barn
我知道，在所有这些名字里。那是我的绝对最爱。但我想说，安吉拉除了猫之外同样著名的，可能还有她的情人们。她有几个。虽然她曾称帕姆为办公室床垫，并且对看到迈克尔和唐娜亲热感到恶心，但安吉拉·马丁和德怀特在仓库里以及办公室里发生过性关系。
and also in the warehouse and also in the office. She dated Andy and the senator. However, she does consider first base to be just a kiss on the forehead and she wouldn't hug Andy in public. So she's an interesting love interest. She's very complex. Yes. And finally, I thought we should note Angela is very good at making brownies. Very good. Yes. I mean, they're Kevin's favorites.
她和安迪以及参议员约会过。然而，她认为的一垒仅限于在额头上亲吻一下，而且她甚至不会在公共场合拥抱安迪。所以她是一个有趣的恋爱对象。她非常复杂。是的。最后，我认为我们应该指出，安吉拉非常擅长做布朗尼蛋糕。非常擅长。是的。我的意思是，那是凯文的最爱。
Double fudge. Yeah. And there you have it. That is your summary Office Bible tribute to Angela Martin. Well, I am so glad that you listed all of the cats because I get asked that a lot. So I'll have to like save that audio clip. Oh, yes. Well, I printed it out for you if you want. I even have a breakdown of when each of the cat's names
双层软糖。是的。这就是全部了。这就是你的办公室圣经摘要对安吉拉·马丁的致敬。嗯，我很高兴你列出了所有的猫，因为经常有人问我这个问题。所以我得把那段音频保存下来。哦，是的。好吧，如果你想要的话，我为你打印出来了。我甚至有一份关于每只猫的名字是什么时候
appeared in the show. Oh my goodness. Yeah, so I can give that to you if you want. Some serious Dr. Tippado action. A little bit. Yeah, well that was a wonderful show Bible. I mean, I did learn a few new things like her address. Yes. Yeah.
在剧中出现的详细统计。哦，天哪。是的，如果你想要的话，我可以把它给你。有点蒂帕多博士（Dr. Tippado）的作风。有一点。嗯，那真是一本精彩的剧集圣经。我的意思是，我确实学到了一些新东西，比如她的地址。是的。是的。
Well, when you did my show Bible, there were things in there I didn't even remember. And it was very fun to hear it Yes. Yeah. Well, when you did my show, Bible, there were things in there I didn't even remember. And it was very fun to hear it all. Yeah. All right. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we are going to go through our Angela Martin favorite moments
嗯，当你制作我的剧集圣经时，里面有些东西我甚至都不记得了。听到这一切真的很有趣。是的。是的。嗯，我们为什么不休息一下呢？当我们回来时，我们将回顾我们心目中的安吉拉·马丁高光时刻
and our areas of interest. Whether it's a family member, friend or furry companion joining your summer road trip, enjoy the peace of mind that comes with Volvo's legendary safety. During Volvo Discover Days, enjoy limited time savings as you make plans to cruise through Muskoka or down Toronto's bustling streets. From now until June 30th, lease a 2025 Volvo XC60 from 1.74% and save up to $4,000 condition supply. This is your GTA Volvo retailer or go to volvo cars.ca for full details. Hey, what's up flies? This is David Spade.
以及我们的兴趣领域。无论您是与家人、朋友还是毛茸茸的同伴一起踏上夏日的自驾游，都可以尽情享受沃尔沃传奇安全性能带来的安心。在沃尔沃探索日（Volvo Discover Days）期间，当您计划穿梭于穆斯科卡（Muskoka）或多伦多繁华的街道时，尽享限时优惠。即日起至 6 月 30 日，租赁 2025 款沃尔沃 XC60，利率低至 1.74%，最高可省 4,000 美元，受条款约束。请咨询您的 GTA 沃尔沃零售商或访问 volvo cars.ca 了解完整详情。嘿，最近怎么样，苍蝇们？我是大卫·斯佩德。
Dana Carvey. Look at, I know we never actually left, but I'll just say it. We are back with another season of fly on the wall. Every episode, including ones with guests, will now be on video. Every Thursday you'll hear us, and see us chatting with big name celebrities. And every Monday you're stuck with just me and Dana.
达纳·卡维。听着，我知道我们其实从未离开过，但我还是要说。我们带着新一季的《墙上的苍蝇》（Fly on the Wall）回来了。每一集，包括有嘉宾的节目，现在都将提供视频版本。每周四，您都可以听到我们并看到我们与大牌名人聊天。而每周一，您只能和我和达纳大眼瞪小眼。
We react to news, what's trending, viral clips. Follow and listen to Fly on the Wall everywhere you get your podcasts. At Desjardins Insurance, we know that when you are a building contractor, wherever you get your podcasts. At Desjardins Insurance, we know that when you're a building contractor, your company's foundation needs to be strong. That's why our agents go the extra mile to understand your business and provide tailored solutions for all its unique needs.
我们对新闻、热门趋势、病毒视频做出反应。在您获取播客的各大平台上关注并收听《墙上的苍蝇》。在道杰斯保险（Desjardins Insurance），我们深知当您是一名建筑承包商时， wherever you get your podcasts. At Desjardins Insurance, we know that when you're a building contractor, 您的公司基础必须坚如磐石。这就是为什么我们的代理商会竭尽全力了解您的业务，并为其所有独特需求提供量身定制的解决方案。
You put your heart into your company. So we put our heart into making sure it's protected. Get insurance that's really big on care. Find an agent today at Desjardins.com slash business coverage. All right, we are back. And you know what we should say, unfortunately, Sam is not here with us today.
您将心血倾注于您的公司。因此，我们也倾注心力确保它受到保护。获取真正注重关怀的保险。今天就在 Desjardins.com slash business coverage 寻找一位代理商。好的，我们回来了。你知道我们该说什么，不幸的是，萨姆今天没有和我们在一起。
He woke up sick and he couldn't come in the studio to celebrate your birthday, but Angela, he says happy birthday. Thank you, Sam. I hope you feel better soon. And I had also asked everybody if they would please pick their favorite Angela Martin moment. I wanna start with this one
他醒来时生病了，无法来工作室庆祝你的生日，但安吉拉，他说生日快乐。谢谢你，萨姆。希望你早日康复。而且我还请大家挑选出他们最喜欢的安吉拉·马丁时刻。我想从这个开始
that was sent in by Denise S. in Medford, Oregon. I have a nice comforter and several cozy pillows. I usually read a chapter of a book and it slides out by 8.30. That's how I sleep at night. Well, Denise, I love that you love that quote because several people have asked me to write that on things like when I sign things. Well, Denise went on to say,
这是俄勒冈州梅德福的丹尼斯·S（Denise S.）发来的。我有一条不错的羽绒被和几个舒适的枕头。我通常读一本书的一个章节，然后在八点半左右就睡着了。这就是我晚上的睡眠方式。嗯，丹尼斯，我很高兴你喜欢那句台词，因为好几个人都要求我在签名时把那句话写在东西上。嗯，丹尼斯接着说道，
the audacity of the documentary crew and the reveal of the question at the end, it's just so perfect. It was really fun. That was a fun one. It is a fun one, like the way it pays off. You realize what they asked you at the very end. Yes. All right. Well, next up, lady,
纪录片摄制组的厚颜无耻以及最后揭晓的问题，简直太完美了。这真的很有趣。那是一个有趣的时刻。这是一个有趣的时刻，就像它的呼应方式一样。你意识到他们在最后问了你什么。是的。好了，接下来，女士，
I'm going to share my favorite. It is from Launch Party. This is a scene that leads into my favorite Angela Martin talking head. It starts with Angela and Phyllis are hanging up a sign and Angela realizes that Phyllis has hung up a sign that says lunch party instead of launch party. And then Phyllis has a talking head
我要分享我最喜欢的。它来自《发布会》（Launch Party）。这是一个引出我最喜欢的安吉拉·马丁访谈独白的场景。故事开始于安吉拉和菲利斯在挂一条横幅，安吉拉发现菲利斯挂的横幅上写的是“午餐派对”（lunch party）而不是“发布会”（launch party）。然后菲利斯有一个访谈独白
where she says she's been doing some research on how to deal with difficult people. Yeah, here it is. So how do you feel about the fact that the banner says lunch? I feel angry. Angry at you. Angry at you for doing something stupid.
她在里面说她一直在做关于如何应对难缠之人的研究。是的，在这里。那么对于横幅上写着“午餐”这件事，你有什么感受？我觉得很生气。生你的气。生你的气，因为你做了件蠢事。
Angry at me for believing you could do something not stupid. I'm so sorry to hear that. That must be awful. It is awful. You've made this day awful. Maybe you could just change the U into an A. Sorry to hear that. That must be awful. It is awful. You've made this day awful. Maybe you could just change the U into an A.
生我自己的气，因为我相信你能做出不蠢的事。听到这个我很遗憾。那一定糟透了。确实糟透了。你把这一天搞得糟透了。也许你只要把U改成A就行了。遗憾听到这个。那一定糟透了。确实糟透了.你把这一天搞得糟透了。也许你只要把U改成A就行了。
Then it would say, lunch party, Kevin. Would it really be better if it said, lunch party? Oh, lunch party. It's supposed to say, launch. Okay, wow, easy booster. See, nobody cares about this party anyway. I care! Plan a party, Angela. Oh, and the entire world will see it. Oh, and here's $65 for your budget. Oh, and here are four idiots who'll do nothing but weigh you down.
那样就会变成，“午餐派对，凯文。”如果上面写着“午餐派对”，真的会更好吗？哦，午餐派对。上面本该写着“发布会”。好吧，哇，冷静点，助威者。听着，反正也没人在乎这个派对。我在乎！策划一场派对吧，安吉拉。哦，全世界都会看到它。哦，这里有65美元作为你的预算。哦，这里有四个除了拖你后腿什么都不会的笨蛋。
Oh, and your cat's still dead. Lady, the whole thing, it's so, it is just so funny. Your reactions to everybody, the, just like how put upon you are by the inefficiency of everyone around you. I don't know, it's just, it's wonderful. In a $65 budget. I know, to throw a party for, how many people are in this office?
哦，你的猫还是死的。女士，整段内容，太好笑了，简直太搞笑了，你对每个人的反应，那种，就像你对周围所有人效率低下感到多么不堪重负一样。我不知道，这简直太棒了。只有65美元的预算。我知道，要为——办公室里有多少人办一场派对？
The whole office. How do you feed everyone? I don't know, especially if you spent a lot of money on a banner that was worded wrong. So listen, Sam couldn't be here, but he did send in his clip. Should we have a listen? Yeah.
整个办公室。你怎么养活所有人？我不知道，特别是如果你花了很多钱在一条写错词的横幅上。所以听着，萨姆不能来，但他确实发来了他的剪辑。我们听听看吗？好的。
Hello, Angela. Happy birthday. I'm really sorry I can't be there today. I am sick. My personal favorite Angela moment is, I forget what episode it's from. It's where Dwight is hitting on Isabel and Angela walks up behind him. Just something about her face. It's so earnest and so sincere in the way Rain
你好，安吉拉。生日快乐。我很抱歉今天不能去。我生病了。我个人最喜欢的安吉拉时刻是，我忘了它是哪一集了。就是德怀特在对伊莎贝尔（Isabel）献殷勤，而安吉拉从他身后走过去。她脸上的表情真是妙不可言。她是那么认真和真诚，雷恩（Rain）的反应
reacts. It's just great. This clip I think is from the bloopers because you can hear everyone laughing afterwards, but it's great. So here it is. What's your blood type? Oh negative. Universal donor. Universal donor. Uh, that's a little bit of a visual one, but I know exactly what he's talking about. The reason why everyone's laughing is because on that particular take, it was the first time we did sort of this gag where our director, Matt Son, was like, Angela, I want you to sneak up as close to Rain, you know, like kind of get almost right under his armpit, like get as close to him as you can and just kind of peer up at him. And we didn't tell Rain how close I was going to get to him.
也很棒。我认为这段剪辑来自NG花絮，因为你可以听到大家事后都在笑，但它真的很棒。所以它在这里。你的血型是什么？O型阴性。万能捐献者。万能捐献者。呃，那是一个有点视觉效果的梗，但我完全知道他在说什么。大家之所以在大笑，是因为在那个特定的镜头中，那是我们第一次做这种恶作剧，我们的导演马特·松（Matt Sohn）说：“安吉拉，我希望你悄悄走到离雷恩尽可能近的地方，你知道的，就像几乎钻到他腋窝底下一样，尽量离他近一点，然后抬头看着他。”我们没有告诉雷恩我要离他有多近。
And so when we did it, when he turned his elbow was like kind of right at my face. So he's like, and he like cursed and everyone started laughing. And then Matt was like, okay, you guys have to do that exactly again. We have to do it again. And then that's the one that ended up in the episode. Well, the other thing about it that's so funny, Angela, it was such a good piece of direction, and you so nail it, is because Rain and Kellan, who played
所以当我们拍的时候，当他转身时，他的手肘几乎就在我脸旁边。所以他就像是，他骂了一句粗口，然后大家都笑了起来。接着马特说：“好吧，你们必须一模一样地再拍一次。”我们必须再拍一次。然后就是最终出现在正片里的那个版本。嗯，关于它搞笑的另一点是，安吉拉，那真是一段出色的导演指导，而且你完成得太棒了，因为雷恩和饰演
Isabel, are so tall. Yes. And you are so sneaky and tiny as you sort of come up and you just appear. And also, normally my character were like really high heels. And for that particular scene, because we wanted that sight gag, I wore like ballerina flats. Oh my gosh. So I'm basically my full five one.
伊莎贝尔的凯伦（Kelen）都太高了。是的。而你又是那么鬼祟和娇小，当你走过来并突然出现时。而且，通常我的角色都会穿非常高的鞋子。但在那一特定的场景中，因为我们想要那个视觉梗，我穿的是芭蕾平底鞋。哦，天哪。所以我基本上就是我1米55的真实身高。
Yes. Right there. Oh my goodness. All right. Cassie, do you have a favorite Angela Martin moment? I do. And I think it's probably the most famous one, but I have to go with it because it's what my heart tells me and it's the safe bandit moment. I think it's just perfect television. Every beat, every moment is perfect.
是的。就在那里。哦，天哪。好吧，凯西，你有一个最喜欢的安吉拉·马丁时刻吗？我有。而且我认为这可能是最著名的一个，但我必须选它，因为这是我内心告诉我的选择，那就是营救邦迪（Bandit）的时刻。我认为这简直是完美的电视节目。每一个节拍，每一个时刻都是完美的。
And when you broke down the episode and talked about all that was involved and the crew, like truly incredible work. So here it is. Remember your exit points. Exit points, people. What's next? Oscar! Stay alive, I'm getting help!
而且当你剖析那一集并谈到涉及的所有内容和剧组时，真的是令人难以置信的工作。所以它在这里。记住你们的疏散点。疏散点，各位！接下来是什么？奥斯卡！坚持住，我去叫人！
Pull me up! You're too heavy! I only weigh 82 pounds! No! Save Bandit! Sometimes you just hear a little bit of a scene and you are right back there. That is one for me.
把我拉上去！你太重了！我只有82磅！不！救救邦迪！有时候你只需听到一小段场景，你就会立刻回到那个时刻。对我来说就是这样。
Like one of the things that cracked me up is after we did our first take, the director for that episode, Jeff Blitz was like, I want to just like up the anxiety of this moment, like up the stakes, like even more, like heighten it. And I didn't intend on doing this, but after I did it, Jeff was like, you have to do that every time.
让我捧腹大笑的事情之一是，在我们完成第一次拍摄后，那一集的导演杰夫·布里茨（Jeff Blitz）说：“我只想让这个时刻的焦虑感升级，就像加大赌注一样，甚至更多，让它更紧张。”我原本不打算这么做的，但在我做完之后，杰夫说：“你每次都必须这样做。”
So Oscar yells down at me and I did this like, you know that like gravel thing you do with your voice? I'm like, I really want to do this! Yeah, yeah. Like I kind of, because I was just so in the moment and he was like, you have to do that every time now. I was like, okay. Oh my gosh.
所以奥斯卡朝我大喊，我做了这样一个，你知道那种用嗓子发出的粗粝声音吗？我说：“我真的想这么做！”是的，是的。就像我有点，因为我太入戏了，然后他说：“你现在每次都必须这样做。”我说，好吧。哦，天哪。
Those are so fun. I loved hearing all of those. Well, Angela, do you have a favorite Angela Martin moment? Oh man. You know, there's so many moments. I'm so thankful I got to play and scenes I got to be a part of. But I have, I think one of my all time favorite speeches
这些太有趣了。我喜欢听所有这些。嗯，安吉拉，你有一个最喜欢的安吉拉·马丁时刻吗？哦，天哪。你知道，有太多时刻了。我很感激我能参与其中并成为其中一部分的场景。但我有一个，我认为是我有史以来最喜欢的演讲
and it's to Phyllis and it's also in Launch Party. Oh my gosh, that is such a good Angela Phyllis episode. Yes, and that is one of my favorite dynamics, is between you and Phyllis. I feel like I could watch a whole show about you guys. I asked for assorted cutlery, and I got back spoons. These are worthless. I want to understand what you're saying, but it's difficult for me when you use that tone.
那是对菲利斯说的，而且也是在《发布会》里。哦，天哪，那真是一集极棒的安吉拉与菲利斯的戏。是的，那是我最喜欢的动态关系之一，就是你和菲利斯之间。我觉得我可以看一整部关于你们俩的剧。我要求提供各式各样的餐具，结果我拿回来的只有汤匙。这些毫无用处。我想理解你在说什么，但当你用那种语气时，这对我很困难。
Phyllis, these are spoons. Spoons have rounded tops and are used to scoop things. What we need are forks, which have prongs or tiny spears on top. And we need knives, which have blades. Do you understand me now? Yes. Goodie. That was such a blast to do.
菲利斯，这些是汤匙。汤匙顶部是圆的，用来舀东西。我们需要的是叉子，上面有尖头或小长矛。我们还需要刀子，上面有刀刃。你现在听懂我的意思了吗？听懂了。太好了。拍那一幕真是太刺激了。
I feel like the reason I love Angela Martin in that episode so much is that she is my interior monologue for every time I've had to deal with an inefficient situation. I managed to suppress it, but on the inside, that is I have a little Angela Martin saying all those things. You're like, I only got 65 bucks and four idiots. Exactly.
我觉得我之所以在那一集中那么喜欢安吉拉·马丁，是因为每当我不得不处理效率低下的情况时，她就是我内心的独白。我设法压抑了它，但在内心深处，我有一个小安吉拉·马丁在说所有这些话。你就像是，我只拿到了65美元和四个笨蛋。完全正确。
Well, that was really fun. I loved hearing everyone's favorite moments. Well, now, Angela, I'd love to turn it over to you. I'd love to hear about your Angela Martin area of interest. OK. First, to kick things off, I'd like to share a character review that I found of Angela Martin, because several of you wrote in to ask me what it was like to play a character that was, well,
嗯，那真的很有趣。我喜欢听每个人最喜欢的时刻。好了，现在，安吉拉，我很想把它交给你。我很想听听关于你的安吉拉·马丁兴趣领域。好的。首先，我想分享一个我找到的对安吉拉·马丁的角色评价，因为你们中有好几个人写信问我，扮演一个
many times very unlikable. She could be hypocritical, judgy, downright mean. And, you know, I have seen the Reddit threads about, you know, some of the most unlikable characters on The Office, and Angela Martin usually makes the list. She also made some internet lists of unlikable characters, like this one titled, quote, "'After re-watching The Office, I made a definitive ranking of all of the characters. Here's what I came up with, from worst to best.'" Oh.
很多时候非常不讨喜的角色是什么感觉。她可能很虚伪、爱评判人、甚至彻头彻尾的卑鄙。而且，你知道，我看到过关于《办公室》里一些最不讨喜角色的红迪（Reddit）讨论串，而安吉拉·马丁通常都榜上有名。她还登上了一些互联网的不讨喜角色榜单，比如这篇标题为，引述：“在重温《办公室》之后，我对所有角色做出了一个权威的排名。以下是我得出的结果，从最差到最好。”哦。
Uh-huh, There are 23 characters. At number 23, ranked the worst, Angela Martin. No. Yes. Okay, this is what- Worse than Ryan Howard? This is what they go on to say. Quote, okay, some might think that this is unfair to her,
嗯哼，有23个角色。在第23位，也就是被评为最差的是安吉拉·马丁。不。是的。好吧，这是——比瑞安·霍华德（Ryan Howard）还要差？这就是他们继续要说的。引述，好吧，有些人可能会觉得这对她不公平，
but honestly, she was just not a good person. The only good thing about her character was how she complimented Dwight. She was a cheater, a liar, and actively aimed to hurt other people, not to mention that she was also annoying, mean, and showed no remorse for her actions. Hmm. Hmm. I do think she did show some remorse. She had some growth. That's the one I don't agree with. And why I would put Ryan Howard lower than Angela was because Ryan was also a liar
但老实说，她真的不是一个好人。她这个角色唯一的优点就是她如何衬托德怀特。她是个骗子、撒谎精，并且积极地想要伤害其他人，更不用说她还很烦人、卑鄙，并且对自己的行为毫无悔意。嗯。嗯，我确实认为她表现出了一些悔意。她有一些成长。那是唯一我不同意的地方。我为什么会把瑞安·霍华德排在安吉拉后面，是因为瑞安也是一个骗子
and a cheater, and he strung people along for his own benefit. He was very manipulative. He was. And he never shows any remorse for it. Whereas Angela, she has growth. So, lady, I would put Ryan Howard as number 23 and maybe you're number 22. I don't know. I definitely hear this person on a lot of those points.
和作弊者，他为了自己的利益把人们牵着鼻子走。他非常有操纵欲。他是的。而且他对此从未表现出任何悔意。而安吉拉，她有成长。所以，女士，我会把瑞安·霍华德排在第23位，也许你是第22位。我不知道。我完全赞同这个人提出的很多观点。
Would you like to know who made the number one best character? Favorite, favorite in this list. Meaning like best person or favorite? Phyllis? Michael Scott. Oh, well, I mean, he's a crowd pleaser. He's a crowd pleaser.
你想知道谁排在了第一位最好的角色吗？在这份榜单中最喜欢、最喜欢的角色是谁？菲利斯？迈克尔·斯科特。哦，好吧，我的意思是，他是个人人喜欢的角色。他是个人人喜欢的角色。
Well, I would like to point out that Angela Martin did not make the most unlikable The Office characters list on MovieWeb.com or ScreenRant.com. I love that you're shouting out the two places that left you off the list. That left you off. Really, thanks guys. Okay. Anyway, I thought we had to address, and all about Angela Martin,
嗯，我想指出的是，安吉拉·马丁并没有登上 MovieWeb.com 或 ScreenRant.com 上《办公室》最不讨喜角色的榜单。我喜欢你大声说出那两个把你排除在外的网站。把你排除在外。真的，谢谢你们，伙计们。好吧。无论如何，我认为我们必须在“关于安吉拉·马丁的一切”中解决
the fact that, you know, she's not very likable a lot of the times. All right. Well, you know, I also felt like a big part of my character was her wardrobe. And the costume department on the office really came through for me and really helped me build this character.
这样一个事实，即你知道，她在很多时候确实不太讨喜。好吧，你知道，我也觉得我角色很大一部分是她的服装。办公室的服装部门真的为我提供了极大的帮助，真正帮助我塑造了这个角色。
So my area of interest is how to dress like Angela Martin. Oh, I love that you're going to talk about this, Angela, because it really is true how there are some roles that you have where your costume is, as soon as you put it on, you just immediately feel more in character. Yeah, like that person. Yes. The first thing you need to know is
所以我的兴趣领域是如何穿得像安吉拉·马丁。哦，我很高兴你要谈论这个，安吉拉，因为确实有些角色，一旦你穿上戏服，你就会立刻觉得自己更融入角色了。是的，就像那个人一样。是的。你需要知道的第一件事是
you do not need to wear pantyhose or stockings of any kind. All right, now that is an Angela Kinsey. Second, you are allowed a comfortable shoe like SAS shoes, but you will also need a three inch heel because the love of your life is very tall. Okay. Third, you need at least one pencil skirt. Four, you will need several floofy blouses with a high collar and a minimum of 32 tiny buttons.
你不需要穿连裤袜或任何种类的长袜。好吧，这很安吉拉·金西。第二，你可以穿舒适的鞋子，比如 SAS 鞋，但你也需要一双三英寸的高跟鞋，因为你一生的挚爱非常高。好吧。第三，你至少需要一条铅笔裙。第四，你需要几件领口很高、至少有32粒小纽扣的蓬蓬衬衫。
Five, you will sometimes wear a sweater vest. Be sure and change out the regular buttons on it for buttons with cat faces. I loved that detail that they did for you. I did too. Six, you will need a color palette. It will be shades of gray and beige, sometimes a pastel if you're feeling flirty. Seven, you will need only one Halloween costume to wear each year. It will be a cat and you will make it yourself. Eight, Christmas is its own category.
第五，你有时会穿一件毛衣背心。确保把上面的普通纽扣换成有猫咪脸图案的纽扣。我喜欢他们为你做的这个细节。我也很喜欢。第六，你需要一个调色板。它将是灰色和米色调，如果你感觉调情的话有时可以加点柔和色。第七，你每年只需要一套万圣节服装。它将是一只猫，而且你要自己做。第八，圣诞节自成一类。
You will need some holiday plaid and you will always wear a Christmas brooch. Nine, should you find yourself by a lake, you will wear a bucket hat. Ah yes, sun protection. That's right. Ten, you will rarely wear dressy trousers, but if you do, they will need to be a dark color, nothing bright, nothing with a print design, nothing flashy. And that's how you can dress like Angela Martin. Now I would add to this that Angela Martin's hair was part of her overall look that was just
你需要一些节日格子呢，而且你必须总是佩戴一个圣诞胸针。第九，如果你发现自己身处湖边，你必须戴一顶渔夫帽。啊是的，防晒。没错。第十，你很少穿正装长裤，但如果你穿的话，它们需要是深色的，不要明亮的，不要印花图案的，不要花哨的。这就是你如何才能穿得像安吉拉·马丁。现在我要补充的是，安吉拉·马丁的头发也是她整体造型的一部分，和她的服装
as important as her costume. So I think you might want to add some sort of braid or tight bun to this list of how to dress like Angela Martin. I don't know, is hair considered dressing? I kind of think it is. Yes, no. I think you will need to make sure that you have something high and tight
一样重要。所以我想你可能想在“如何穿得像安吉拉·马丁”的这份清单上添加某种辫子或紧紧的圆发髻。我不知道，头发算作穿着吗？我有点觉得是的。是的，不。我想你需要确保你有一个
and very groomed. Yes. No hair out of place. No. And I do want to give a shout out. This is a gift that I treasure. I framed it. It hangs right outside my closet door.
高而紧且非常整洁的发型。是的。没有一根头发是乱的。没有。而且我想大声感谢一下。这是我珍视的一份礼物。我把它装裱起来了。它就挂在我衣柜门外。
A wonderful artist named Morgan made such a beautiful watercolor for me and it features several of Angela Martin's looks. Yes, you know Morgan is the artist who did Beasley's botanicals. That's right. Where she made a little drawing of every one of the plants
一个名叫摩根（Morgan）的杰出艺术家为我创作了一幅非常美丽的水彩画，上面画了安吉拉·马丁的几种造型。是的，你知道摩根就是创作了《比斯利的植物学》（Beasley's Botanicals）的艺术家。没错。她在那里画了帕姆桌上
that was ever on Pam's desk. Right. And she made a mug out of it. I have it as a mug. I have the original. And then she made one of little, they're little like watercolors of all of your elaborate blouses.
曾经出现过的每一株植物的小画。对。她还把它做成了马克杯。我有一个马克杯。我有原作。然后她画了小型的、它们就像是你所有精致衬衫的小型水彩画。
Yes, and dresses. And I just love this so much. I'm gonna share it in our stories. Morgan, I just, I smile every day I see it. Well, Angela, my area of interest is called Angela Martin fan theories. Oh, there's fan theories? There are many fan is called Angela Martin fan theories. Oh, there's fan theories?
是的，还有裙子。我太喜欢这个了。我要把它分享到我们的快拍里。摩根，我就是，每次看到它我都会微笑。嗯，安吉拉，我的兴趣领域叫做安吉拉·马丁粉丝理论。哦，有粉丝理论吗？有很多关于安吉拉·马丁的粉丝理论。
There are many fan theories about Angela Martin. And I realized that, you know, some of them we've touched on, but many of them we haven't, I feel like, discussed quite enough. Okay. And when we opened up our mailbag for questions for this episode, so many fan theory letters.
有很多关于安吉拉·马丁的粉丝理论。我意识到，你知道，其中一些我们已经涉及了，但其中许多我们还没有，我觉得，讨论得足够充分。好的。当我们为这一集的问题打开邮箱时，收到了如此多的粉丝理论信件。
Okay. I mean, I feel like I know a few of them, but I didn't know there were many, many. Well, we're gonna discuss three today. Okay. Here is the first one from Frankie M. in Burkhamsted, UK. I was just rewatching Fun Run,
好吧。我的意思是，我觉得我知道其中一些，但我不知道有那么多、那么多。嗯，我们今天要讨论三个。好的。这里是第一位来自英国伯克hamsted的弗兰基·M（Frankie M.）发来的。我当时正在重温《趣味赛跑》（Fun Run），
and I realized that the death of Sprinkles and the breakdown of Duangela's relationship is completely Pam's fault. Oh, she was organizing for people to visit Meredith in the hospital and Angela said she couldn't go because of her cat. Pam guilts her into going anyway by bringing up the PPC, which is why Dwight is left in charge of Sprinkles.
我意识到小饼干的死以及“双安吉拉”关系的破裂完全是帕姆的错。哦，她当时在组织大家去医院探望梅雷迪思（Meredith），而安吉拉说她因为猫不能去。帕姆通过提起派对策划委员会（PPC）来内疚她非去不可，这就是为什么德怀特被留下照顾小饼干。
And Linda C from Phoenix, Arizona said, how do you feel about the theory that Pam is responsible for Sprinkles. And Linda C. from Phoenix, Arizona said, how do you feel about the theory that Pam is responsible for Sprinkles' death because she guilted Angela into visiting Meredith instead of going home at lunchtime? Oh, that's a good one. I feel like we touched on this a little bit when we broke down that episode. But lady, so many letters and there's like articles online
来自亚利桑那州菲尼克斯的琳达·C（Linda C）说，你对“帕姆因为内疚安吉拉在午餐时间去探望梅雷迪思而不是回家，从而对小饼干的死负有责任”这个理论有什么看法？哦，那是个好观点。我觉得我们在剖析那一集时稍微触及过这一点。但是女士，有那么多的信件，网上还有文章
about is Pam really responsible for the death of Sprinkles? I mean, if Angela really connected with that, look out Pam. I know. I mean, here is my thought. I think Pam was kind of right to encourage Angela to visit Meredith in the hospital, but at the same time, like as Jenna,
在讨论帕姆是否真的对小饼干的死负有责任？我的意思是，如果安吉拉真的将这两者联系在一起，帕姆可要小心了。我知道。我的意思是，我的想法是，我认为帕姆鼓励安吉拉去医院看望梅雷迪思并没有错，但与此同时，作为詹娜，
if I knew how sick like someone's cat was, I would certainly excuse them from attending because Sprinkles really needed her medicine. Yeah, and unfortunately, Angela thought Dwight could handle it when he could not. Yeah, I think if it were me in that moment, I would just be like, here's a card, give it to Meredith.
如果我知道某人的猫病得有多重，我肯定会准许他们不用出席，因为小饼干真的很需要它的药。是的，不幸的是，安吉拉以为德怀特能搞定，然而他搞不定。是的，如果换作当时的我，我可能只会说：“这是张卡片，帮我交给梅雷迪思。”
I'm gonna go check on my cat. I know. But yeah, she kind of felt peer pressure a little bit. I mean, I think it's fair to say that both Pam and Dwight contributed to Sprinkles death, but then also maybe Meredith did by getting hit by the car in the first place. Well, then we need to point to Michaelinkles death. But then also maybe Meredith did by getting hit by the car in the first place. Well then we need to point to Michael.
我要回家去看看我的猫。我知道。但对，她多少有点感受到同辈压力了。我的意思是，可以说帕姆和德怀特都对小饼干的死负有责任，但然后也许梅雷迪思也有责任，因为她一开始就被车撞了。嗯，那我们需要指向迈克尔。
Exactly, this goes, this trail goes back. Maybe it's all the way to Michael for creating this moment. Kind of true. All right, fan theory number two. Oh my gosh, this was also a fan mail flurry. People would like us to discuss are Garbage and Bandit the same cat just renamed?
没错，这个线索，这个轨迹可以追溯回去。也许这可以一直追溯到迈克尔，因为他制造了这一刻。有点道理。好吧，粉丝理论第二个。哦，天哪，这也是一封粉丝邮件风暴。大家希望我们讨论的是：垃圾和邦迪是同一只猫只是改了个名字吗？
From Alpha M in Utah, in Dunder Mifflin Infinity, part one, Dwight releases a cat that he had trapped for Angela named Garbage, tries to win you over with Garbage. He releases this cat down in the warehouse area. Okay. And then in money part two, Andy gives Angela a cat that he found in the warehouse, in this same general area. So the theory goes that garbage is the same cat.
来自犹他州的阿尔法·M（Alpha M）说，在《办公室超长版：无限》（Dunder Mifflin Infinity）第一部分中，德怀特释放了一只他为安吉拉设陷阱抓来的名叫“垃圾”的猫，试图用垃圾来赢得你的芳心。他在仓库区域放生了这只猫。好的。然后在《金钱》（Money）第二部分中，安吉拉收到了安迪送的一只猫，是他在仓库里发现的，就在这个相同的通用区域。所以这个理论认为垃圾就是同一只猫。
So basically they're saying the cat that Dwight released into the warehouse and then the cat that Andy brings to Angela are one in the same. Yes, but then the cat that Angela gets from Andy is the same cat that lives in her drawer that then goes in the ceiling. So that must be Bandit. So the question is from Jenby in Crawford, Georgia,
所以基本上他们是说，德怀特放生到仓库里的猫和安迪带给安吉拉的猫是同一只。是的，但是安吉拉从安迪那里得到的猫，就是那只住在她抽屉里后来又钻进天花板的猫。所以那一定就是邦迪。所以来自佐治亚州克劳福德的珍比（Jenby）提出的问题是：
garbage is bandit, right? Was the same cat used? Well, no, the same cat was not used. The cat that played garbage is not the same cat that played bandit. However, we did talk about this in our breakdown of money part two, and you and I agreed Angela,
垃圾就是邦迪，对吧？使用的是同一只猫吗？嗯，没有，饰演垃圾的猫和饰演邦迪的猫不是同一只。然而，我们在剖析《金钱》第二部分时讨论过这一点，你和我一致认为，安吉拉，
that we think that garbage is the cat that Andy trapped and gave to Angela. We agreed that she renamed him Bandit. Yes, we followed the logic that this is the same cat that was in the warehouse. Yes. Yeah, I remember that. And then I think I shared this, but just for everyone to know,
我们认为垃圾就是安迪设陷阱抓住并送给安吉拉的那只猫。我们一致认为她把它改名为邦迪。是的，我们遵循了这个逻辑，即这就是仓库里的那只猫。是的。是的，我记得。然后我想我分享过这一点，但为了让大家知道，
the cat that played garbage was one of the biggest cats I've ever held in my life. It was so huge. It was so big. Yes. And I don't think I could have put that cat up in the ceiling. So that's the question, which is like, was it intended to be the same cat?
饰演垃圾的猫是我这辈子抱过的体型最大的猫之一。它太巨大了。它太大了。是的。而且我觉得我不可能把那只猫塞进天花板里。所以问题就在于，它是被设定为同一只猫吗？
Like, is this theory like what was intended? And did we just switch cats because you couldn't physically throw the original cat up into the ceiling? We had to recast? Or was it like, we don't know. Yeah, we don't know, except I do agree. I think that garbage is bandit, that Angela renames it.
就像，这个理论是原本的意图吗？我们只是换了猫，因为你无法把最初那只猫物理上扔进天花板里？我们必须重新选角？还是说：我们不知道。是的，我们不知道，但我确实同意。我认为垃圾就是邦迪，安吉拉给它重新起了名字。
I also think Angela would never ever call a cat garbage. So if she was given that cat again from Andy and she's trying to be spiteful to Dwight, and this time she's taking the cat, even though it was the same cat, she would rename it for sure. Well, I went back and I watched this part of the episode where Angela discovers this cat in a box on her desk.
我也觉得安吉拉绝对、绝对不会把一只猫叫作垃圾。所以如果安吉拉再次从安迪那里得到那只猫，而她正试图对德怀特心怀恶意，并且这一次她收下了这只猫，即便它是同一只猫，她也绝对会给它改名字。嗯，我回过头去看了这一集的这一部分，安吉拉在办公桌上的盒子里发现了这只猫。
There's a look that she shares with Dwight when she receives the cat, but then thanks Andy for it. And then Dwight's face just falls. He's so sad. And I think that she knows it's the cat he gave her. And now Andy's getting credit for it. Like she wouldn't accept it from Dwight, but she'll accept it from Andy.
当她收到这只猫时，她和德怀特交换了一个眼神，然后却为此感谢了安迪。接着德怀特的脸直接垮了。他太伤心了。我觉得她知道这就是他送给她的猫。而现在安迪却因此得到了赞赏。就像她不肯接受德怀特的，但她会接受安迪的。
And it's like this extra dagger. Yeah, because you would have to know, and Dwight would have to know, how much willpower it would take for Angela not to accept a cat from anyone. Correct. All right, well, I enjoyed that discussion. I did too.
这就像是又补了一刀。是的，因为你必须知道，德怀特也必须知道，安吉拉不接受任何人的猫需要多大的意志力。没错。好吧，我挺喜欢这个讨论的。我也很喜欢。
Now we're moving into fan theory number three, which is that Angela is not really a vegetarian. Oh. Lady, there is so much conflicting evidence. I have a question for you. What is it? Did people bring up the chicken piccata at the hospital? Yep.
现在我们要进入粉丝理论第三个，那就是安吉拉其实不是素食主义者。哦。女士，有太多相互矛盾的证据了。我有个问题要问你。是什么？大家在医院里有没有提到过鸡肉比卡塔（chicken piccata）？ yep。
Okay, yeah. So it all starts in email surveillance. She's at the barbecue, Jim offers her some barbecue and Angela says, I'm a vegetarian. Then in business ethics, she only eats potato salad. This is when Meredith has slept with the rep and has gotten everyone's steak. That's right.
好吧，是的。所以这一切都始于邮件监控。她在烧烤派对上，吉姆拿烧烤给她吃，安吉拉说：“我是个素食主义者。”后来在商业道德课上，她只吃土豆沙拉。这就是梅雷迪思和代表睡过觉、还拿了所有人牛排的那一集。没错。
And then there's other little moments where this idea of her being a vegetarian plays out. For example, Kate H. from Parkersburg, West Virginia pointed out, while watching Dinner Party, I noticed something that is a true testament to the attention to detail in the show. When everyone finally gets their long awaited dinner, Angela Martin covers the meat on her plate with a napkin.
接着还有其他一些小细节，体现了她是个素食主义者的设定。比如，来自西弗吉尼亚州帕克斯堡的凯特·H.指出，在看《晚宴》这一集时，我注意到一个细节，这真正证明了该剧对细节的一丝不苟。当每个人终于吃上了期盼已久的晚餐时，安吉拉·马丁用餐巾盖住了盘子里的肉。
I thought it was so cool. I improvised that. Yay. I just thought she wouldn't want to look at it. Kate said, as a super fan, I know that Angela is a vegetarian, so it came as no surprise, but I love when there are little details
我觉得这太酷了。那是即兴表演。耶。我只是觉得她不会想看着它。凯特说，作为超级粉丝，我知道安吉拉是个素食主义者，所以这并不奇怪，但我很喜欢那些小细节
that are callbacks or support a character's backstory. So wonderful support for that character backstory. But there are a lot of times when Angela seems to not be a vegetarian. For example, in Money, when Andy asked her out to dinner, she says she'll go, but she insists, quote, no vegetables and no seafood. What is she eating?
它们是前后呼应，或是支撑了角色的背景故事。对角色背景故事的支撑真是太棒了。但也有很多时候，安吉拉似乎并不是个素食主义者。比如在《金钱》那一集里，安迪约她吃晚饭时，她说她会去，但她坚持要求，原话是，“不要蔬菜，也不要海鲜”。她到底吃什么？
Listen, I have two very good friends who are vegetarians, and they don't like vegetables. What do they eat? And they don't like seafood. What is she eating? Listen, I have two very good friends who are vegetarians and they don't like vegetables. What do they eat? And they don't like seafood. What do they eat? They eat a lot of like beans, pastas, but they don't want a Brussels sprout or carrots. Like they eat potatoes.
听着，我有两个很好的朋友是素食主义者，而他们不喜欢蔬菜。那他们吃什么？他们也不喜欢海鲜。她到底吃什么？听着，我有两个很好的朋友是素食主义者，而他们不喜欢蔬菜。那他们吃什么？他们也不喜欢海鲜。他们吃什么？他们吃很多像豆子、面食类的东西，但他们不要球芽甘蓝或胡萝卜。比如他们吃土豆。
So that wasn't too far off the mark for me. She just might not like some vegetables. Okay. But then as you mentioned, Angela, how do you explain this one? In Jury Duty, she says Philip was conceived after quote, too much wine and chicken piccata. And also in Moving On, she eats the meat stew
所以这对我来说不算太离谱。她可能只是不喜欢某些蔬菜。好吧。但正如你所提到的，安吉拉，你怎么解释这个？在《陪审团义务》中，她说菲利普是在“太多的红酒和柠檬鸡”之后怀上的。还有在《继续前进》中，她吃了肉炖菜
with Aunt Shirley, which you said she did as a courtesy. Yeah, I sort of thought maybe she just had the broth. The one that is the most puzzling to me is the chicken piccata, the wine sauce. So I'm like, did she decide to eat meat when she was pregnant? Oh, when she wasn't pregnant yet. No. No.
和雪莉阿姨一起，你说那是出于礼貌才吃的。对啊，我当时想也许她只喝了汤。最让我感到困惑的是柠檬鸡和那道红酒酱汁。所以我当时想，难道她怀孕的时候决定吃肉了？哦，当时她还没怀孕。不。不。
That's how she got pregnant. That's how she got pregnant. That's the one that's like, that doesn't quite track. Yeah. Well, listen, why don't we take a break and when we come back, we're gonna do our all about Angela Martin Q&A. I'm so excited about this.
她就是那样怀上的。她就是那样怀上的。这就是那个让人觉得有点说不通的地方。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来后，我们要进行关于安吉拉·马丁的问答环节。我对此兴奋不已。
You guys wrote in the best questions and I'm excited to hear the answers. I am too. I am too. I am too. I am too. Get to Toronto's main venues like Budweiser Stage and the new Roger Stadium with Go Transit. Thanks to Go Transit's special online e-ticket fairs, a $10 one-day weekend pass offers unlimited
你们写来了最棒的问题，我很高兴听到答案。我也是。我也是。我也是。我也是。乘坐Go Transit前往多伦多主要场馆，如百威舞台和全新的罗杰斯体育场。借助Go Transit特别的在线电子客票优惠，10美元的周末一日通票可在周末的任何一天或节假日提供无限次
travel on any weekend day or holiday, anywhere along the Go network. And the weekday group passes offer the same weekday travel flexibility across the network, starting at $30 for two people and up to $60 for a group of five. Buy your online GoPass ahead of the show at Gotransit.com slash tickets. No Frills delivers. Get groceries delivered to your door from No Frills with PC Express. Shop online and get $15 in PC Optimum Points on your first five orders. Shop now at No Frills.ca. This episode is brought to you by Dzone.
在Go网络沿线的任何地方出行。工作日团体通票则在整个网络中提供相同的工作日出行灵活性，两人起步价30美元，五人团体最高60美元。在演出前登录Gotransit.com/tickets购买您的在线GoPass。No Frills为您送货上门。通过PC Express将No Frills的杂货送到您家。在线购物并在前五笔订单中获得15加元的PC Optimum积分。立即在NoFrills.ca购物。本集由Dzone为您倾情呈献。
For the first time ever, the 32 best soccer clubs from across the world are coming together to decide who the undisputed champions of the world are in the FIFA Club World Cup. The world's best players, Messi, Holland, Kane, and more are all taking part. And you can watch every match for free on Dazon, starting on June 14th and running until July 13th.
国际足联俱乐部世界杯史上首次汇聚了来自全球的32家最佳足球俱乐部，共同决出无可争议的世界冠军。梅西、哈兰德、凯恩等世界顶级球员都将参赛。您可以从6月14日开始到7月13日结束，在Dazon上免费观看每一场比赛。
Sign up now at dazon.com slash FIFA. That's D-A-Z-N dot com slash FIFA. All right, we are back. And I'm just so excited to dig into this Q&A section. Angela, I think the character that you developed is so just deliciously complex and interesting. She is full of surprises and she is nothing like you in real life. In fact, we got a letter that made me chuckle and I'd like to start with it. Okay.
立即在dazon.com/FIFA注册。即D-A-Z-N dot com slash FIFA。好了，我们回来了。我太兴奋了，迫不及待地想要深入这个问答环节。安吉拉，我觉得你塑造这个角色实在是太微妙复杂、太有趣了。她充满了惊喜，而且她在现实生活中跟你一点也不像。事实上，我们收到了一封让我哑然失笑的信，我想从它开始。好的。
It's from Lisa in Calgary, Alberta, who said, "'Not a question, just a cute story for Angela.' I was telling my mom, a new office fan, who I got listening to the podcast too." Thanks, Lisa. I know, getting us new listeners. Yeah. I was telling my mom about the podcast
这是来自阿尔伯塔省卡尔加里的丽莎说的：“这不是一个问题，只是给安吉拉的一个可爱的小故事。”我把我妈妈拉成了《办公室》的新粉丝，我也让她开始听这个播客了。谢谢丽莎。我知道，给我们带来了新听众。对。我跟我妈聊起了这个播客
and my son Liam piped up and said, it is good. It's good to know Angela isn't a bee in real life. Ha ha ha. Thanks, Liam. Anytime we talk about the office, he assures people that Angela is a really good actor and not really a bee.
然后我儿子利亚姆插话说道：“挺好的。知道安吉拉在现实生活中不是个B（贱人），这感觉真好。”哈哈，谢谢利亚姆。每次我们谈论《办公室》时，他都会向人们保证安吉拉是个非常好的演员，并不是真的那么讨厌。
Ha ha ha. Liam out there spreading the good word for me. I know this family is doing a lot for us. I know. All right, well, let's dig into the questions. Question number one, it's a twofer. First from Colette V in Long Island, New York. Hello ladies.
哈哈，利亚姆在外头为我传播正能量呢。我知道这个家庭为我们付出了很多。我知道。好吧，那我们来深入探讨这些问题吧。问题一，这是一箭双雕。首先来自纽约州长岛的科莱特·V。女士们好。
So I know you've poked fun at Jenna for her actory background prep, but I was wondering Angela, how much of a background did you mentally develop for Angela Martin? Like, I wonder what happened in her upbringing that made her so particular? Mm-hmm.
所以，我知道你们曾拿珍娜的演员背景准备开过玩笑，但我很好奇，安吉拉，你为安吉拉·马丁在心理上构建了多少背景故事？比如，我很好奇她的成长经历中发生了什么，才让她变得如此挑剔？嗯哼。
And then Eli B. from Maryland said, I'd like to know about Angela Kinsey's backstory for Angela Martin. Is she from Scranton? How did she end up at Dunder Mifflin? Why did she choose accounting? Okay. Well, Collette and Eli, those are great questions. You know, I never thought Angela was from Scranton.
然后来自马里兰州的伊莱·B.说：“我想知道安吉拉·金斯利为安吉拉·马丁设定的背景故事是什么。她是斯克兰顿人吗？她是怎么落脚邓德米夫林的？她为什么会选择会计？”好吧，科莱特和伊莱，这些都是好问题。你知道的，我从来没觉得安吉拉是斯克兰顿人。
I saw her sort of like my friends that I grew up with in Indonesia whose parents were in the military, and they moved around a lot, which might also explain her need for structure and why she liked Dwight. And I also saw her as someone that needed order and rules. And I think that's why she picked accounting. You know, numbers make sense. Yeah. And as far as my actor prep, you know,
我觉得她有点像我在印度尼西亚一起长大的朋友，他们的父母在军队里，经常搬家，这也许也能解释她对秩序的需求以及她为什么喜欢德怀特。我也把她看作是一个需要秩序和规则的人。我想这就是她选择会计的原因。你知道的，数字是有逻辑的。是的。至于我的演员准备工作，你知道的，
I'm a people watcher and I kind of collect characters as I go through life. I'll jot down little notes about people I meet. Jenna, I'll leave you messages about people who I think of collect characters as I go through life. I'll jot down little notes about people I meet. Jenna, I'll leave you messages about people who I think are great characters. We kind of do that all the time with each other. You do it more though, Angela, in your descriptions of people you've observed,
我是一个善于观察的人，在人生的旅途中，我算是在收集各种角色。我会记下关于我遇到的人的小纸条。珍娜，我会给你留言，讲讲那些我认为我在人生旅途中收集了各种角色的人。我会记下关于我遇到的人的小纸条。珍娜，我会给你留言，讲讲那些我认为是很棒的角色的人。我们俩经常这样互动。不过你做得更多，安吉拉，在你对我观察到的人的描述中，
they're always so loving and so detailed, and you find like, just in the world, you find so many characters. This is so true about you. Well, I think people are so fascinating, you know, and I usually mesh a few of those different people when I start to create a role. So for Angela Martin, she was a combination of this woman
他们总是那么充满爱意又细节满满，你发现，就好像在这个世界上，你能发现这么多的角色。关于你，这太真实了。嗯，我觉得人们太迷人了，你知道的，当我开始塑造一个角色时，我通常会把几个不同的人融合在一起。所以对于安吉拉·马丁来说，她是这个女人的结合体：
who I worked with at 1-800-Dentist. She was the office manager. She was in charge of front reception, the mailroom. And I've shared this before on the podcast. She was in charge of front reception, the mail room. And I've shared this before on the podcast. She was in charge of planning the Christmas party, the big company Christmas party. And she was allowed a few people to help her and you got a little extra money.
我在1-800-Dentist工作时共事过的一个女人。她是办公室经理。她负责前台接待和收发室。我以前在播客里分享过这个。她负责前台接待和收发室。我以前在播客里分享过这个。她负责策划圣诞派对，也就是公司的大型圣诞派对。她被允许找几个人来帮她，而且你可以得到一点额外的奖金。
And I signed up to do it, but man was this party high stakes for her. She took it so seriously. And I've shared this before, but she literally yelled at me because I was doing a Christmas bow incorrectly on the stair banister leading into the party. She was like, let me do it. I was like, okay. So I had that lady in mind. And then the second person I used for Angela Martin
我报名去做了，但是天哪，这个派对对她来说赌注太高了。她太认真了。我以前分享过，但她真的对我大喊大叫，因为我在通往派对的楼梯扶手上绑圣诞蝴蝶结时绑错了。她说：“让我来。”我说：“好吧。”所以我的脑海里一直记着那个女士。然后我用来塑造安吉拉·马丁的第二个人
was my grandmother. Now she wasn't judgy or mean, but she was very, very proper. She was just a very proper lady. She always dressed up for the day. She wore lots of brooches, and she had a lot of cats. She had this barn, and she had all these barn cats that she would feed. I mean, I remember one time going over there, and I looked out the back door
是我外祖母。现在，她并不苛刻也不刻薄，但她非常非常规矩。她就是一位非常规矩的女士。她总是精心打扮过一天，戴着许多胸针，而且她养了很多猫。她有一个谷仓，里面养了好多谷仓猫喂它们。我的意思是，我记得有一次去她那儿，我往后门外面看去
because it was getting near dinnertime, and there were so many cats. And part of my family lore story is that as her eyesight grew worse, as she aged, one time a bobcat came up to the back door. And she fed the bobcat. No. Yes.
因为快到晚饭时间了，外面有那么多的猫。我的家族传说中的故事之一是，随着她年纪渐长、视力恶化，有一次一只山猫走到了后门。她居然喂了那只山猫。不会吧。是的。
And she was like, oh, I've got the biggest cat. And we were all there one time and it locked up. My dad was like, mom, that's a bobcat. So that is also part of Angela Martin for me. Now, is that why you had a picture of her on your desk? Yes. Yes, I had a picture of her and I. It was a black and white photo.
她当时说：“哦，我养了只最大的猫。”有一次我们都在那儿，它把门锁上了。我爸说：“妈，那是山猫。”所以这也是安吉拉·马丁对我来说的一部分。那么，这就是为什么你桌上放着她的照片吗？是的。是的，我有一张我和她的合影。那是一张黑白照片。
It was in a frame that said, I heart grandma. And my eyes are closed in the picture. It's so wonderful. But she would do that. She would frame pictures of you and there would be someone's finger over the lens, but it went in a frame. Yeah.
相框上写着“我爱奶奶”。照片里我的眼睛是闭着的。太棒了。但她就会那样做。她会把你的照片框起来，虽然照片里可能会有某个人的手指挡住镜头，但它还是被装进相框里了。是啊。
You know? Yeah. It didn't matter if your eyes were open or closed. She was gonna put it in a frame and display it. Another thing I drew on as I shaped Angela Martin was, actually, and I've never shared this before, I've never told you this, Jenna. What?
你知道吗？是的。你的眼睛是睁着还是闭着并不重要。她就是要把它装进相框里展示出来。我在塑造安吉拉·马丁时借鉴的另一个东西是，实际上，我以前从未分享过这个，我从来没跟你说过这个，珍娜。什么？
So when I was doing all my auditions, you know, I auditioned first for Pam. Yep. And then between that time and when I came in for Angela Martin was several months. And I had started reading the book, The Age of Innocence by Edith Wharton. Okay.
所以当我进行所有试镜的时候，你知道的，我最先去试镜帕姆。没错。然后在那段时间和后来我去试镜安吉拉·马丁之间隔了几个月。我当时开始读伊迪丝·沃顿的书《纯真年代》。好吧。
And I look back now on that and I think about how informing that book was for me as I went in. I didn't know. I didn't know I was going to audition for Angela Martin. It just sort of happened. And I was immersed in this world of like 1870s New York society. It was the golden age.
现在回想起来，我觉得那本书在我去试镜时对我产生了多大的启发。我当时并不知道。我不知道我要去试镜安吉拉·马丁。这只是碰巧发生了。我沉浸在1870年代纽约上流社会的这个世界里。那是黄金时代。
There were all these social rules. There was repressed feelings and unconsummated love. And I just feel like Angela is someone that would have felt right at home in an older, more conservative world, for sure. And that's what I was reading when I went into audition. And I'd sort of forgotten about that. And then I went back to my journal that I was keeping that year.
有各种各样的社会规则。有压抑的感情和未完成的爱。我只是觉得安吉拉绝对会在一个更古老、更保守的世界里感到如鱼得水。这就是我去试镜时正在读的书。我其实有点把这事给忘了。然后我翻回了那一年我写的日记。
And I wrote in my journal about this book and how I kept thinking about it. And I wrote in my journal about this book and how I kept thinking about it. And I kept thinking about these characters and how the ending broke my heart. And that's what I was reading when I went in for my audition. I am getting chills at the serendipity of that.
我在日记里写了这本书，以及我如何一直在思考它。我在日记里写了这本书，以及我如何一直在思考它。我一直在想这些角色，以及结局是如何让我心碎的。这就是我当年去试镜时正在阅读的内容。这种巧合让我起了一身鸡皮疙瘩。
How there are these times in an artist's life where there are things that are informing your art and your career and you don't even know it. You don't even know like why you're doing it or how it's going to happen. It's this like it's part of the weird magic of our industry and what we do that oh my god I love that story so much. Yeah I was sort of inviting this creative narrative. I didn't even realize I was inviting. And when I went into a read for the role of, at the time, just the persnickety accountant, right?
在艺术家的生活中，有时会有一些东西在潜移默化地启发你的艺术和职业生涯，而你甚至一无所知。你甚至不知道你为什么要在这样做，或者它将如何发生。这就好比是我们行业和我们所做事情的奇妙魔法的一部分，天哪，我太喜欢这个故事了。是的，我当时有点在招引这种创作叙事。我甚至没有意识到我在招引它。而当我进去为一个当时只是“挑剔的会计”的角色读剧本时，对吧？
I made this choice to have really, really good proper posture. And I sat shoulders back, like straight up. And almost to the point where like, I like got a back ache after. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because you were really forcing this posture. Yeah, that's how I went in the room with this posture. And I think that book sort of was informing me.
我做了一个选择，保持非常非常挺拔的仪态。我双肩后展，就像这样笔直地坐着。甚至到了那种……我后来背部都有点酸痛的程度。对，对，对。因为你真的在强迫这种仪态。对，我就是带着这种仪态走进房间的。我觉得那本书在某种程度上启发了我。
So I sort of feel like I went in there with this sort of like persona I didn't even realize. Mm-hmm, yeah. I just love that so much. Now, lady, I have usually been reaching out to Greg about the origin of people's names, but you said you played a part. I mean, obviously Angela is Angela,
所以我感觉自己当时是带着一种我甚至都没有意识到的角色面具走进去的。嗯哼，是的。我太喜欢这个了。好了，各位，我通常会向格雷格打听角色名字的来源，但你说过你参与其中了。我的意思是，很显然安吉拉就是安吉拉，
but that you played a part in how she got the last name Martin. Will you share? I will. So Greg came over to the accounting department and he was like, hey, you guys, we need last names for you. And we were like, oh, he goes, why don't you jot down a few that you think fit your character? And we were like, oh, he goes, why don't you jot down a few that you think fit your character?
但你对她如何拥有“马丁”这个姓氏也有所贡献。能分享一下吗？好的。所以格雷格来到会计部，他说：“嘿，伙计们，我们需要给你们起个姓氏。”我们当时就说：“哦。”他说：“你们为什么不随手记几个你们觉得适合自己角色的姓氏呢？”我们当时就说：“哦。”他说：“你们为什么不随手记几个你们觉得适合自己角色的姓氏呢？”
And we were like, okay. And Brian felt very strongly about Malone. Yes, and that connection to the Irish. And I wrote a few down, and one of the ones I wrote was Martin. At the time I had a friend, like we were like all in our twenties, and his name was Martin.
然后我们就说：“好吧。”布赖恩对“马龙”这个姓非常坚持。是的，还有与爱尔兰的渊源。我写了几个，其中一个我写的姓是马丁。当时我有一个朋友，我们差不多都是二十来岁，他叫马丁。
And I thought, oh, that might be kind of fun. I didn't even really think about it. And me and Brian and Oscar talk about this, but Greg ended up picking Malone, Martin and Martinez. Oh my gosh, the three M's of accounting. That's right. So we always thought that would be a fun spinoff, you know. Yes.
我觉得，哦，这可能挺有意思的。我当时甚至没多想。我和布赖恩以及奥斯卡谈过这个，但格雷格最后选了马龙、马丁和马丁内斯。天哪，会计部门的三个M。没错。所以我们一直觉得这会是个有趣的衍生剧，你知道的。对。
M, M and M. Yes, accounting firm. Yeah. Well, Angela, we got a fun spinoff, you know? Yes. M, M, and M. Yes, accounting firm. Yeah. Well, Angela, we got a fun letter from someone about your name, Angela Martin, and it made me laugh because remember we did have a discussion about Mensa? Yes, they didn't let you in. They didn't let me in.
M，M和M。是的，会计事务所。好吧，安吉拉，我们得到了一封关于你的名字“安吉拉·马丁”的有趣信件，它让我笑出声来，因为还记得我们曾讨论过门萨俱乐部吗？是的，他们没让你进去。他们没让我进去。
I didn't. I'm sure I'm not in either. I didn't make it. But here is a really fun share from Emily L. in Charlotte, North Carolina, who said, hello, I recently joined Mensa and was checking out their website to see what they offer to members.
我没进。我敢肯定我也没有。我没考进去。但这里有一条来自北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的埃米莉·L.的非常有趣的分享，她说：“你好，我最近加入了门萨，正在浏览他们的网站，看看他们为会员提供什么。”
First of all, Emily, congratulations. Yeah. Emily said, they have a gift shop online and various things to purchase. I saw they have membership certificates that you can purchase with your name on them. Well, all of the examples say Angela Martin. No way.
首先，埃米莉，恭喜你。是的。埃米莉说：“他们有一个在线礼品店和各种可供购买的东西。我看到他们有会员证书，上面可以印着你的名字购买。”好吧，所有的示例上面都写着“安吉拉·马丁”。不会吧。
Yes. Angela, Angela Martin is the Mensa certificate shop store, I guess, template example. It's so amazing. She put a link. So we're gonna have to link to this in stories. I'm looking up Mensa right now. I'm looking up the website. It's mensastore.com slash collections slash members. Okay. Gosh, just so you guys know, Mensa has a lot of merch.
是的。安吉拉，安吉拉·马丁就是门萨证书网店的模板范例。这太神奇了。她发了一个链接。所以我们得在动态里放上这个链接。我正在查门萨。我正在查他们的网站。网址是mensastore.com/collections/members。天哪，让大家知道，门萨有好多周边商品。
Oh really? Yes. But she's absolutely right. If you go to that link and I'll put it in our stories, it says Angela Martin. There you go. That's so funny. I wonder if someone that does merch for Mensa
哦，真的吗？是的。但她说得完全没错。如果你去那个链接——我会把它发到我们的动态里——上面写的就是安吉拉·马丁。给你。太搞笑了。我在想，设计门萨周边商品的人
is an office fan. They must be. And also this does beg the question, do you think Angela Martin is in Mensa? Oh, yes. I do too. I do. I do as well.
是不是《办公室》的粉丝？他们肯定是。而且这也引发了一个问题，你觉得安吉拉·马丁会是门萨会员吗？哦，是的。我也是这么认为的。我也是。我也是。
This is why life is so frustrating to her. Yes. I do too. I do. I do as well. This is why life is so frustrating to her. Yes. All right, that was just question number one. Look at how much wonderful information we got from just one question. Here's question two. We've talked so much on the show, and about how different you are from your character.
这就是为什么生活对她来说如此令人沮丧。是的。我也是这么认为的。我也是。我也是。这就是为什么生活对她来说如此令人沮丧。是的。好吧，那只是第一个问题。看看我们仅从一个问题中就获得了多么丰富的美妙信息！这是第二个问题。我们在节目中聊了那么多，关于你和你的角色有多么不同。
I mean, anyone who listens to the podcast can hear that. And we had a lot of people write in about the differences between you and your character. For example, Amanda E from Illinois said, I'm so excited for this episode because I think Angela is one of the most underrated characters in the show. A question I'm curious about, and I'm sure many people will
我的意思是，任何听这个播客的人都能听得出来。我们有很多人写信来谈论你和你的角色之间的差异。例如，来自伊利诺伊州的阿曼达·E.说：“我太期待这一集了，因为我觉得安吉拉是剧中被严重低估的角色之一。我很好奇的一个问题是，我确信许多人也会问：
ask is, how did it feel to play a character that has a demeanor so opposite of your natural self? Was it difficult to play a cold and stony character for almost a decade? Oh, well, Amanda, that's really nice of you to say all of that. You know, Angela Martin was just an escape for me. In real life, I am not a very confrontational person. I don't like to make a fuss. So getting to play someone who's not afraid to just let people have it, it was actually really fun.
扮演一个行为举止与你的天性截然相反的角色是什么感觉？扮演一个冷酷无情的人物将近十年，这难吗？”哦，好吧，阿曼达，你能说这些真是太好了。你知道的，安吉拉·马丁对她来说只是我的一种逃避。在现实生活中，我并不是一个很有对抗性的人。我不喜欢小题大做。所以能扮演一个不怕直接给别人难堪的人，其实真的很有趣。
I do have to say, I had the hardest time being mean to Phyllis. I know. Phyllis is literally the nicest person on the earth. I know, and she just has the sweetest face, and it was so hard to be mean to her. And I did struggle with how judgy Angela could be. And I also struggled with all the buns.
我必须得说，对菲利普刻薄是我经历过最难的事。我知道。菲利普真的是地球上最温柔的人。我知道，她有着最甜美的面孔，对她刻薄真的太难了。而且安吉拉有多刻薄，这让我很纠结。我还跟那些发髻较劲过。
Literally headaches. Headaches, like the pulled hair and the bobby pins. I don't know how people wear such high tight buns for hours and hours. And my friends did joke that if I would go and meet them out after work, after a day of filming, go do improv or whatever. They said I would have resting bitch face
简直是头痛。头痛，比如紧绷的头发和发夹。我不知道人们怎么能把这么高、这么紧的发髻戴上好几个小时。我的朋友们开玩笑说，如果我下班后去跟他们聚聚，在经历了一整天的拍摄之后去玩即兴表演什么的。他们说我会一直带着一张臭脸，
that I had spent all day not allowing myself to smile. And people, I've had strangers like stop me and be like, hey, you okay? And I'm like, what? No, I'm great. But I guess I just have this like scally frown on my face. Did you feel like that finally went away after the show ended?
因为我一整天都在克制自己不准笑。而且人们，我曾被陌生人拦下来问：“嘿，你还好吗？”我说：“什么？没有，我挺好的。”但我想我的脸上就是带着这种冷冰冰的愁容。你觉得这种表情在剧集结束后终于消失了吗？
Do you still get that from people? I feel like... No, not as much anymore. I think my face is finally relaxed. It took years though. Well, I have a question, sort of a follow-up, which is how has playing the role of Angela Martin affected you in real life?
你现在还会收到人们的这种反应吗？我觉得……不，没那么多了。我想我的脸终于放松了。不过这花了好几年。嗯，我有一个问题，算是后续问题，那就是扮演安吉拉·马丁这个角色对你的现实生活有什么影响？
I mean, I know you said people would stop you on the street or I guess another way to say it is like, how has it affected your career being so known for a type of person that is like so different from who you are. And we also got a fan letter from Kelly W. in West Africa slash Oregon slash Ontario. Kelly. You get around Kelly.
我的意思是，我知道你曾说人们会在街上拦住你，或者换句话说，因为人们太熟悉你扮演的这种与你本人截然不同的人，这如何影响了你的职业生涯？我们还收到了来自西非斜杠俄勒冈斜杠安大略的凯利·W的粉丝来信。凯利，你可真到处跑啊，凯利。
Who said, Angela Martin has quickly become my absolute favorite character. She always has the best reactions and also fully embodies the concept of Schneidenfreude. Look it up. Schneidenfreude, okay. Knowing Angela's true personality now makes it an even more outstanding performance.
她说：安吉拉·马丁迅速成为了我绝对最喜欢的角色。她总是反应最好，而且完美地诠释了幸灾乐祸这个概念。去查查词典吧。幸灾乐祸，好吧。现在了解了安吉拉的真实个性，让这成为了一个更加出色的表演。
My question is, was Angela being typecast before the office or did it begin afterwards and have you had to work hard to get different roles? Oh gosh. It's a lot of questions I just threw at you. Well, you know, no, Angela was the first BITCH I ever played. Okay. Yeah.
我的问题是，安吉拉在《办公室》之前就被定型了，还是在这之后开始的？你不得不努力去争取不同的角色吗？天哪，我刚向你抛出了一大堆问题。嗯，你知道的，不，安吉拉是我演过的第一个碧池。好吧，是的。
And Greg did say to me, you know, there's good career safety because in an office, there's always one bitch. So he said that's actually job security. Yes, for future office related projects. That's right. But you know, after the office I did, I got a series of roles where people wanted me to play the persnickety lady.
格雷格确实对我说过，你知道的，这有很好的职业安全感，因为在一个办公室里，总有一个碧池。所以他说这其实是工作保障。是的，为了未来与办公室相关的项目。没错。但你知道，在《办公室》之后，我确实接到了一系列角色，人们希望我扮演那个挑剔的女士。
Yeah. I had a few jobs right after the office. One was on New Girl, and I did not play the bitch on that one. So that was fun. But I did get a series of offers to play the bitch. And I only took one because it was with Betty White. It was hot in Cleveland.
是的。在《办公室》结束后不久我有过几份工作。其中一份在《杰茜驾到》里，我在那部剧里没有演碧池。所以那很有趣。但我确实接到了一系列让我演碧池的邀约。我只接了一个，因为那是和贝蒂·怀特合作的。那是《热力克利夫兰》。
That's a good one. And I was like, I mean, she's just this legend and I just want to occupy the same space with her just once. And I was trying not to just go back to that well of like, oh, people are wanting to cast me as the person that they lady. But I remember telling my agents, yes, I will do it. I will absolutely do it.
那是个不错的剧。我想，我的意思是，她简直是个传奇，我只想和她在同一个空间呆哪怕一次。我尽量不去重新涉足那种老套路，就是“哦，人们想把我选为那个挑剔的女士”。但我记得我告诉我的经纪人，会的，我会演的，我绝对会演。
And I found an interview where I was asked about it. I was on the set of Hot in Cleveland and here's what I had to say. ["Hot in Cleveland"] Hello, my name is Angela Kinsey and I will be playing Dr. Teresa Carson. I am the head mistress of a snooty preschool here on Hot in Cleveland.
我找到了一段采访，当时有人问我这件事。我在《热力克利夫兰》的片场，以下是我的话：[《热力克利夫兰》] 大家好，我是安吉拉·金西，我将饰演特蕾莎·卡森医生。我是《热力克利夫兰》里一家势利幼儿园的园长。
Wow, that is a big hand. She reminds me a little bit of my office character and the fact that she's, well, she takes everything very seriously, but she wears a lot better suits. You know, I met Betty White and she held my hand when we were talking and I was like, she's holding me. She's like so cute, I didn't want to hug her.
哇，掌声真热烈。她让我想起了一点我的办公室角色，因为她——嗯，她对一切都非常认真，但她穿的套装要好得多。你知道吗？我遇到了贝蒂·怀特，当我们说话时她握着我的手，当时我想，她正握着我呢。她太可爱了，我真想抱抱她。
And I don't know why everyone's so tall, minus Betty. Of course, Betty's taller than me, because I'm 5'1". But no, it's like the land of tall people. This week, we also have guest star in Craig Ferguson, who I love. He's already cracking me up, so I'm a little worried about tape night, because he looks at me with the goofiest look on his face so many times in the scene,
我不知道为什么每个人都那么高，除了贝蒂。当然，贝蒂比我高，因为我身高只有5英尺1英寸。不，这简直就像是高个子国。本周，我们还有客串明星克雷格·法格农，我很喜欢他。他已经让我笑个不停了，所以我有点担心录制之夜，因为在场景里他用最滑稽的表情看着我好多次，
and I just lose it. So yeah, I realized I was playing another version of Angela Martin on that show, but I just was so delighted to be there. But it is one reason why I was so thrilled to be in Haters Back Off on Netflix and the Tall Girl movies, because I got to play sort of just like these moms
然后我就笑场了。所以，是的，我意识到我在那部剧里演的是另一个版本的安吉拉·马丁，但我只是太高兴能参与其中了。这也是为什么我如此激动能参演网飞的《恶魔退散》和《高个子女孩》电影，因为我得以扮演那些很有趣的角色——那种妈妈们，
that were very interesting like characters, but they weren't bitchy. And then your Hallmark Christmas movie. Oh my gosh. Is maybe the closest thing to you in real life. Probably. Just like you love a holiday. I do love a holiday.
她们是非常有趣的角色，但并不刻薄。然后是你的霍尔马克圣诞电影。天哪。也许是最贴近你现实生活的东西。可能吧。就像你热爱节日一样。我是真的很热爱节日。
You're a good neighbor. I'm not gonna make everyone wear a onesie all day though. That's true. You love a holiday, but you don't force people toie all day though. That's true. You love a holiday, but you don't force people to dress up or anything. That's true. All right, Angela, question number four. We got this fan question from Ella M. in Louisiana who said,
你是个好邻居。不过我不会让每个人一整天都穿着连体衣。确实。你热爱节日，但你不会强迫别人盛装打扮什么的。确实。好吧，安吉拉，第四个问题。我们收到了来自路易斯安那州的粉丝埃拉·M的提问，她说：
Angela, your character changes so much over the course of nine seasons. She shows emotion to Dwight and even Pam at times. In early season, she's strictly private and severe, but toward the end, she is more open with her coworkers and shows different sides of herself. How did you show this new emotional side of Angela that people sympathize with in the later seasons while also still maintaining her stern personality?
安吉拉，在九季的过程中，你的角色发生了巨大的变化。她对德怀特甚至有时对帕姆表现出情感。在早期几季中，她严格保守秘密且严厉，但到了尾声，她对同事们更加坦诚，展现了她不同的一面。在后期几季中，你是如何展现安吉拉这种能让人产生共鸣的新情感一面，同时又保持她严厉个性的？
And also, Kristen A. from Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania said, looking back on Angela's journey, is there a particular moment where you feel she grew the most as a character or one that you were particularly proud of her? Such thoughtful questions. I'm really just moved by the time and care that people put into writing these questions.
还有，来自宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的克里斯汀·A说，回看安吉拉的旅程，有没有哪一个特定的时刻，你觉得她作为角色成长最大，或者是你特别为她感到骄傲的时刻？多么深思熟虑的问题。大家花时间和心思写下这些问题，真的让我很感动。
I know. So good, right? So nice of them. One of the things I loved about the fact that our show was on for nine years is that you really felt the passage of time with these characters, with this world. And all of the characters got progressively more comfortable with the documentary crew being there. Just naturally you would. And I do think a lot of the characters over time evolved and changed. And I always felt like for Angela, it was the love of Dwight that helped her come out of her shell. And he challenged her in so many ways and she loved the challenge.
我知道。太棒了，对吧？他们太好了。我喜欢我们节目播了九年的原因之一，就是你能真切地感受到这些角色、这个世界时间的流逝。所有的角色都随着纪录片摄制组的存在而变得越来越自在。这是很自然的。而且我也确实认为很多角色随着时间推移都在演变和改变。我一直觉得对安吉拉来说，正是对德怀特的爱帮她走出了壳子。他在很多方面挑战了她，而她热爱这种挑战。
It made her try new things and meet new people and do experiences that she would have never done except that she loved him. And I think she was the better for it. And Angela, do you have a moment where you were particularly proud of the character? I was most proud of Angela's growth with her relationship to Oscar. Yeah. I always truly saw Oscar as Angela Martin's best friend in the office.
这促使她尝试新事物、结识新朋友，去体验那些如果不是因为爱他她永远都不会去做的事。我认为她因此变得更好了。安吉拉，你有没有哪个时刻特别为这个角色感到骄傲？我最骄傲的是安吉拉在与奥斯卡的关系上的成长。是的。我一直真心把奥斯卡视为安吉拉·马丁在办公室里最好的朋友。
He's who she would talk to and commiserate with and they had the same taste as men. Yes. And although they certainly had their differences of opinion and they would often butt heads, I always believe she really cared for him. So I was really happy when the writers wrote the arc where Oscar offers Angela and baby Philip
他是她会倾诉、会同悲共苦的人，而且他们对男人的品味是一样的。是的。尽管他们肯定有分歧，也经常针锋相对，但我一直相信她真的很在乎他。所以当编剧写了奥斯卡邀请安吉拉和婴儿菲利普
to come live with him. I loved their dynamic as roommates. That was so much fun to play. And if you watch the wedding of Dwight and Angela, it is Oscar who is taking care of baby Philip. So she trusts him with the things that matter most to her. Yeah, that's beautiful. Yeah. So that growth in that relationship meant a lot to me.
来跟他一起住的剧情时，我真的很高兴。我喜欢他们作为室友的化学反应。演起来太有趣了。如果你看德怀特和安吉拉的婚礼，正是奥斯卡在照顾婴儿菲利普。所以她把对她最重要的事情托付给了他。是的，太美妙了。是的。所以这种关系的成长对我意义重大。
Well, listen, Angela, you also mentioned Duangela. Lady, I know that you and Rain share a special bond after playing one another's fictional love interests for nine years. Can you talk a little bit about it? Yeah, I mean, you know, it's so interesting to me because pretty much right away, the first time we had to be in a scene together where there was this undercurrent of romance, you know, we just had an instant chemistry
好吧，听着，安吉拉，你也提到了“德安吉拉”（Duangela）。亲爱的，我知道你和雷恩在扮演彼此九年的虚构恋人后，分享着一种特殊的羁绊。你能稍微谈谈吗？是的，我的意思是，你知道的，这对我来说非常有趣，因为几乎从一开始，我们第一次必须在一场带有这种浪漫潜流的场景中合作时，你知道的，我们之间就有一种即时的化学反应，
and he had sat at that desk across the way for a while. You know, I don't know I didn't ever see who Angela's relationship would be in the office Like I just assumed she would have a relationship outside of the office and the minute the writers wrote that storyline It just instantly made so much sense And I remember at the table read when it was revealed that their Birkenstocks were rubbing back and forth at Jim's Barbecue, the whole table, like the whole room let out this like, oh, and there was like a light bulb, light bulb,
他已经在对面那个桌子坐了一会儿了。你知道，我不知道……我从没想过安吉拉在办公室里会和谁谈恋爱，我只是以为她会在办公室外面谈恋爱。而当编剧写出那个故事线的那一刻，一切瞬间都变得那么顺理成章。我记得在剧本围读时，当揭晓他们的勃肯鞋在吉姆的烧烤摊上互相蹭来蹭去时，整张桌子，就像整个房间都发出了“哦”的声音，就像亮起了一个灯泡，灯泡，
like everyone, it was like, oh my gosh, of course, of course, Dwight and Angela. I hadn't thought of it at all, you know? And then we didn't get much direction about our characters and who they were to each other in this relationship. We were given great dialogue, but all the rest of it just really happened spontaneously. I think it was just Rainn being Dwight
就像每个人都觉得“哦天哪，理所当然，理所当然，德怀特和安吉拉”。我之前完全没想到过，你知道吗？然后我们并没有得到太多关于我们的角色以及在这段关系中彼此定位的指导。我们得到了很棒的台词，但其余的一切真的都是即兴发生的。我想那只是雷恩在扮演德怀特，
and me being Angela Martin. It just all kind of happened. You've said that thing where when you auditioned with John, it was like you guys were doing this dance, but neither of you even knew it, you know? It was as if they turned on a song and John and I both started dancing the same dance routine, but we'd never talked about it.
而我扮演安吉拉·马丁。一切就这么自然而然地发生了。你曾说过，当你和约翰一起试镜时，感觉你们在跳一门舞，但你们两个甚至都不知道，你知道吗？就好像他们放起了一首歌，然后约翰和我开始跳同一支舞蹈动作，但我们从没讨论过。
Yeah, that's exactly what I felt with Rain. I knew whatever he did as Dwight, it was so instinctively in me how Angela would respond. with Rain, I knew whatever he did as Dwight, it was so instinctively in me how Angela would respond. And doing those scenes with him were such a joy. And it's also funny, and I think maybe why we have chemistry, because we really are like brother and sister, and we really just tease the crap out of each other,
是的，这正是我对雷恩的感觉。我知道无论他作为德怀特做什么，安吉拉会作何反应是如此本能地刻在我骨子里的。和他拍那些戏简直是一种纯粹的快乐。而且也很有趣，我想这也许就是为什么我们有化学反应，因为我们真的就像兄妹一样，我们真的会狠狠地捉弄对方，
and we're real smart asses to one another. We just played doubles tennis together a while back and he came up to me and he was like, I think they're hitting them too because they know they'll get the point. They're avoiding me. And I said, Rain, they've hit them to you. You couldn't run and get that.
而且我们对彼此都尖酸刻薄。不久前我们一起去打双打网球，他走到我面前说：“我觉得他们把球打给他们是因为他们知道能得分。他们在躲着我。”我说：“雷恩，球明明是打给你的。你自己跑不过去接。”
Like you literally like do some cardio. You know what I mean? Like we just kind of always go at each other like that, but it's always loving. And my favorite thing is when I get a text from him that's like, hey idiot, I miss you. And I'm like, I miss you too, dumb ass. But yeah, he was just there.
就像你字面意思上说的那样，做点有氧运动。你知道我的意思吗？我们总是喜欢这样互相打趣，但这总是充满爱意的。我最喜欢的是收到他发来的短信，上面写着：嘿，笨蛋，我想你了。然后我会回：我也想你，小蠢货。不过说真的，他当时就在那里。
I don't know how to explain it. All right, lady. During our All About Pam episode, I shared just there. I don't know how to explain it. All right, lady. During our All About Pam episode, I shared about the music I listened to that made me cry as Pam. And you said you would share your Angela crying song. So do tell. Okay.
我不知道该怎么解释。好吧，女士。在我们关于帕姆（Pam）的那期节目中，我分享了...当时我就在那。我不知道该怎么解释。好吧，女士。在我们关于帕姆的那期节目中，我分享了关于我听了会哭的音乐，作为帕姆的我。你说过你会分享你安杰拉（Angela）的哭泣之歌。所以，讲讲看吧。好的。
Well, when I first started acting, I had taken a class that explored emotions and scenes. You know, we would take a scene, we would write markers alongside the dialogue that would show the emotion going on in the subtext of whatever we were saying. And as part of that class, we explored how music can affect you
嗯，当我刚开始演戏时，我上过一个探索情感和场景的表演班。你知道的，我们会拿一个剧本，在台词旁边写下标记，以此来展示我们所说的话背后潜台词中的情感。作为该课程的一部分，我们探讨了音乐如何影响你
and help you be prepared for a scene that has a lot of emotion. We had to pick a song, go up on stage, sit in a chair by ourselves facing the entire class, the teacher would hit play, and then we would have to slowly cry throughout the song in front of everyone. Oh my gosh!
并帮助你为一个充满情绪的场景做好准备。我们得挑一首歌，走上台，独自坐在椅子上面向全班同学，老师会按下播放键，然后我们必须在所有人的注视下，随着音乐缓缓落泪。哦天哪！
It was so daunting and terrifying, and I did it, and this is the song I picked. It's called, That's the Way Love Goes. I've been throwing horseshoes That's the way love goes. Clover, yet you ran with me, chasing my rainbows. Honey, I love you too, and that's the way love goes. Okay, so you seem like you're getting a little choked up even just listening to that clip. Does it still trigger you? Yeah, I mean, okay, when I picked that song, my dad was still alive, but my dad loved Merle
这太令人畏惧和恐惧了，但我做到了，这就是我选的歌。它叫《那就是爱走过的方式》（That's the Way Love Goes）。我一直在扔马蹄铁，这就是爱走过的方式。三叶草，你却跟我一起奔跑，追逐我的彩虹。亲爱的，我也爱你，这就是爱走过的方式。好吧，所以你看起来有点哽咽，哪怕只是听了听这段剪辑。这还会触动你吗？是的，我的意思是，好吧，当我选这首歌时，我爸爸还活着，但我爸爸喜欢梅尔
Haggard. Okay. He loved all the old country musicians. Yeah. And the interesting thing for me now is that I think that song always just made me think of just this unconditional love that I had from my family and what that means to me. Now for me, when I have to get emotional in a scene, I don't need the song anymore.
哈格德（Merle Haggard）。好的。他喜欢所有老派的乡村音乐。是的。现在对我有意思的是，我觉得这首歌总是让我想起家人给予我的这种无条件地爱，以及这对意味着什么。现在对我来说，当我在一个场景中需要流露情感时，我不再需要这首歌了。
I think a lot of life has happened to me and I will sort of tap into some of the sadness that life has brought and then you're there. And so I think hearing that song now and sharing it with you, because I've never shared it with you before, and you're someone who holds such a special place in my heart, that I just thought about how thankful I am to have you in my life and to have this job that we get to do together.
我觉得生活中发生了很多事，我会去触碰生活带来的悲伤，然后情绪就到位了。所以我想现在听到这首歌并与你分享，因为我以前从未和你分享过，而你在我心中占据着如此特殊的位置，我只是想到了我是多么感谢你出现在我的生活中，以及我们能一起做这份工作。
So my tears and my emotion this job that we get to do together. So my tears and my emotion are very connected to the fact that I feel so safe sharing with you, Jenna. Oh, my gosh. So that's kind of why I got a little teary is that I was like, it felt so lovely to be able to share something like that with you. Well, thank you.
所以我的泪水和情感我们一起合作的这份工作。所以我的泪水和情感，与我感到和你分享非常安全这一事实息息相关，珍娜（Jenna）。哦，天哪。所以这就是为什么我有点想哭，因为我觉得能够与你分享这样一件事情是如此美好。好吧，谢谢你。
Lady, I'm so glad that we're doing this episode and that you're getting to share so much about your process and your approach to character, because as we all know, I will drone on and on and on about my process as I am a nerdy, nerdy theater, nerdy nerd. And I love to break down character. I love to talk to other actors about how they do it. You do not often share those things.
女士，我很高兴我们正在做这期节目，并且你得以分享了这么多关于你的表演过程和塑造角色的方法，因为众所周知，我会喋喋不休地谈论我的过程，因为我是一个书呆子气、热爱戏剧的书呆子。我喜欢剖析角色。我喜欢和其他演员讨论他们是如何做到的。你却不常分享这些。
You're very, very humble, but you are a very technically proficient actor. You are a thoughtful actor. You add complexities to your character. And this has been such a joy getting to draw that out of you for the world to know, which I knew, but for the world to hear the time and care that you put into your acting work.
你非常非常谦逊，但你是一个技术非常熟练的演员。你是一个深思熟虑的演员。你为你的角色增加了复杂性。把这些从你身上挖掘出来让全世界知道，这是一件多么令人高兴的事——虽然我早就知道，但让全世界听到你在表演工作中所投入的时间和心思。
Oh, I've loved it. This is your theater nerd dream. Yes, and also because I'm getting to get you to talk about it. Yeah, I don't know why I'm very shy about it. I don't know what that is. I just sort of keep more of that to myself, maybe because I feel a little vulnerable sharing about it,
哦，我很喜欢。这是你这个戏剧书呆子的梦想。是的，也是因为我能让你谈论它。是的，我不知道为什么我对这事非常害羞。我不知道那是为什么。我只是倾向于把这些更多地留给自己，也许是因为我觉得分享这些会让我感到有点脆弱，
but I'm happy to do it here with you. All right, well, to finish things up, we got a couple questions about what has happened to Angela since the show has ended. We got a question from Emily M. in Brisbane, Australia, who said, Ms. Angela, can I ask, where you see Dwight and Angela now? Did they have more children?
但我很高兴在这里与你分享。好了，为了结束这个话题，我们收到了几个关于安杰拉在节目结束后经历了什么的问题。我们收到了来自澳大利亚布里斯班的艾米丽·M（Emily M.）的问题，她说：“安杰拉女士，请问，你觉得现在德怀特（Dwight）和安杰拉在哪里？他们有更多的孩子吗？”
Did Angela get her pair of small, well-behaved boys in the end? I would love to hear your thoughts on Dwight and Angela and how their life played out together. Miranda B. from Brazil was wondering, did Angela stop working at Dunder Mifflin after they got married? Oscar has her position as head of the accounting department,
安杰拉最终有没有生下一对乖巧的小男孩？我很想听听你对德怀特和安杰拉以及他们如何共同度过人生的看法。来自巴西的米兰达·B（Miranda B.）想知道，安杰拉在他们结婚后是否停止了在邓德米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）的工作？奥斯卡（Oscar）接替了她会计部门主管的职位，
and Dwight describes Angela as his, quote, former accountant. But do you think she would be happy being a homemaker? Because I've always felt that Angela is the kind of woman who likes having a career. Finally, Gavin Jay from Cardiff, Wales said, When Angela's cats got taken away by animal control near the end of season nine, after leaving Senator Robert Lipton, did she eventually get them back? Please say yes. As a cat dad, I hope the answer is a positive one.
而德怀特将安杰拉描述为他的“前会计”。但你认为她会乐于做个家庭主妇吗？因为我一直觉得安杰拉是那种喜欢拥有自己事业的女性。最后，来自英国卡迪夫的加文·J（Gavin J.）说：“当安杰拉的猫在第九季末离开参议员罗伯特·利普顿（Senator Robert Lipton）后被动物控制中心带走时，她最终把它们找回来了吗？请说‘是’。作为一个猫爸，我希望答案是肯定的。”
So, Angela, where are Dwight and Angela? Did they have more kids? Did she keep working and did she get her cats back? First of all, this is a very international question. We have Australia, Brazil and Wales. That is awesome. Okay, you guys, here are my thoughts. I definitely think Dwight and Angela had more children.
所以，安杰拉，德怀特和安杰拉现在在哪？他们有更多的孩子吗？她还在工作吗？她把猫找回来了吗？首先，这是一个非常国际化的问题。我们有来自澳大利亚、巴西和威尔士的提问。这太棒了。好的，各位，以下是我的想法。我绝对认为德怀特和安杰拉有了更多的孩子。
I definitely think she got her pair of well-behaved boys. And I think they're very happy. I think they found their person and they're living their life on that beet farm. I think, Miranda, in answer to your question, I think that Angela is probably running the bed and breakfast on Shruit Farms. That is, yes. Oh, I like that.
我绝对认为她得到了她那对乖巧的小男孩。而且我认为他们非常幸福。我认为他们找到了属于彼此的那个人，并在那座甜菜农场上过着他们的生活。我认为，米兰达，作为对你问题的回答，安杰拉可能在舒鲁特农场（Schrute Farms）经营着加早餐旅馆。是的。哦，我喜欢这样。
I think she would probably want to be a very hands-on mom. So I think she would probably even maybe homeschool. But I think she is running the bed and breakfast, and I think she does all the bookkeeping for the farm. It's a very big property, you know? It's a very big property. is running the bed and breakfast. And I think she does all the bookkeeping for the farm. It's a very big property, you know? It's a very big property. So I think she does the bookkeeping.
我想她可能会想成为一个亲力亲为的妈妈。所以我认为她甚至可能会选择在家教育。但我认为她在经营加早餐旅馆，而且我认为她为农场做了所有的记账工作。你知道，这是一个很大的产业，对吧？这是一个很大的产业。在经营加早餐旅馆。而且我认为她为农场做了所有的记账工作。你知道，这是一个很大的产业，对吧？这是一个很大的产业。所以我认为她负责记账。
The Shroots now also own the business park. So I think Angela has quite a bit of accounting that she's still doing. And lastly, Gavin, I do think she got all of her cats back. Oh, good. 100%. And I think they got all of her cats back. Oh, good. 100%. And I think they're all on the farm. I mean, there was a deleted scene that was written
舒鲁特家族现在还拥有那个商业园。所以我认为安杰拉仍有很多会计工作要做。最后，加文，我确实认为她把所有的猫都找回来了。哦，太好了。百分之百。而且我认为他们把她的猫都找回来了。哦，太好了。百分之百。而且我认为它们都在农场里。我的意思是，剧本里曾有一个被删减的场景
that her cats attacked the doves that are released at her wedding. Yes. So I do think all of her cats are there on the farm. Don't you worry. Aw. Well, lady, I loved this episode all about Angela Martin and Angela Kinsey's birthday.
她的猫袭击了在她婚礼上放飞的鸽子。是的。所以我确实认为她所有的猫都在农场里。别担心。哦。好吧，女士，我很喜欢这期关于安杰拉·马丁和安杰拉·金斯利生日的节目。
It was super fun. And before we go, I wanted to give a shout out to Kaylee from Tyler, Texas. I have driven through Tyler many times. And Kaylee said she felt a real connection to Angela Martin. And here's what she wrote. I just want to send some love for my girl, Angela Martin. She is the character I relate to the most, though hopefully not the bitchiness and judgment.
这真的超级有趣。在我们离开之前，我想向来自德克萨斯州泰勒市的凯利（Kaylee）表示感谢。我曾多次开车穿过泰勒。凯利说她对安杰拉·马丁有着真正的共鸣，以下是她写的内容：“我只想为我的女孩安杰拉·马丁送去一些爱。她是我最有共鸣的角色，尽管希望不是那种刻薄和评判。”
And I think she doesn't get enough credit. As a rule follower and introvert who often feels more comfortable holding some boundaries between my work life and my personal life, Angela makes sense to me. She's not perfect by any stretch, but she's a hardworking, dedicated woman who is a reasonable person in a very unreasonable workplace. In the Dundees, it's funny when she refuses to get up
并且我认为她没有得到足够的认可。作为一个遵守规则且内向的人，她常常觉得在工作生活和个人生活之间保持一些界限会更舒适，安杰拉让我感同身受。她绝非完美，但她是一个勤奋、敬业的女性，在极其不合理的工作场所中保持着理性。在邓迪奖（Dundies）那一集里，当她拒绝起身
and accept the tight ass award, but in real life, Michael is beyond inappropriate. Angela stands up for herself by saying no, and I appreciate that. And one last thought, having a theme for a party can make it more fun, even if she might be a little too strict sometimes. So thank you, Angela Martin, for making all of us, quote,
去领‘死板屁股奖’时很好笑，但在现实生活中，迈克尔（Michael）的行为远远超出了得体的范畴。安杰拉通过说不来捍卫自己，我很赞赏这一点。最后一点，为派对设定一个主题可以使其更有趣，即使她有时可能有点太严厉了。所以谢谢安杰拉·马丁，让所有像我们这样的人——引用原话
buy the book, work until five, spreadsheet making people out there feel seen. I love you both. Aw. Thanks, Kaylee. Kaylee, I love your take on Angela Martin. I love that you're relating to all those things. What a great episode. Thank you, everybody.
‘买书、工作到五点、制作电子表格的人’——感到被看见。我爱你们两个。哦。谢谢你，凯利。凯利，我喜欢你对安杰拉·马丁的看法。我很高兴你能对所有这些事情产生共鸣。多棒的一期节目啊。谢谢大家。
And thank you guys all so much for your questions. They were so, just really wonderful. And I hope this wasn't too much Angela Martin for everyone, but what a great fun birthday. And I can't wait to have some of my cake. I will not eat it on the mic, but I am about to have a piece of birthday cake. All right, everyone. Thanks for writing in. We'll see you next week. See you then.
也非常感谢大家提出的所有问题。它们真的非常非常棒。我希望这期节目没有让大家觉得安杰拉·马丁的成分太多，但这真是一个快乐有趣的生日。我迫不及待想吃点我的蛋糕了。我不会在麦克风前吃，但我马上要吃一块生日蛋糕了。好了，各位。谢谢你们来信。我们下周见。回头见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. I'm gonna be a star There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》（Office Ladies）。《办公室女士》是Audacy节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安杰拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins），我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科（Ainsley Bubbaco）。Audacy的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《鲁珀特树》（Ruppertree）。我将成为一颗星本期节目尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。